Blade,
but things got delayed.
Two point seven.
Hey,
so tom,
you recently went on a bike out here.
Sober October is fucking over,
but I get through them.
I mean I got through.
I think the real question is how are you
feeling?
I feel great.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I was.
I've said this ad nauseum.
I feel ridiculous saying it.
One of my funnest months of my entire
life.
It was very educational month for me.
It was,
it was a learning experience.
I thought that I really thought that
the,
the exercise and discipline is the super
beneficial.
Trying to do something,
restrict something.
Yeah.
And like,
you know,
the fucking class has got tedious for
all of us.
Everybody was like you were saying it's
a chore.
Especially like when I went on a trip,
you know,
like a road trip where I was like
traveling every day to a new city,
you know,
so when I got back I was like,
I'm going to go like eight days in a
row.
That's what I did.
I finished it off with nine days in a
row.
That kind of sucks.
I thought the Grand Canyon or something.
The weird thing about,
I knew I was gonna be home for nine days
now,
so I planned it that way,
but the weird thing about it was that it
was almost like a,
Oh man,
they're gonna fucking vision quest or
something like that.
I knew that I.
When I got to that 15th Day,
I was like Giddy.
That was in class.
I was like,
wow,
can't believe it's going to go down.
And as I was starting the breathing
thing,
I was thinking at the end when I'm doing
that breathing exercise,
I'll be fucking done.
Yeah,
no,
I was really excited.
I did 14 with you guys and that next day
I was like,
this shit is over.
And I had four days to go.
People were like,
go for 20.
And I was like,
okay,
I got my 15th,
14th,
or was he the best class that ever
taken?
Really Halloween theme.
Hold on,
hold on,
hold on.
And I walk in,
we pull our maths in.
The room isn't as hot as to our liking.
Oddly enough,
we're not experts at this and she's
like,
you know,
it's was kind of a Halloween theme.
I hope you guys are cool with like a
little heart lighted approach.
Arina get Nigga all right,
time to do breathing exercises and you
hear ghost buster smiling doodle whole
class.
It's like thriller,
ghostbusters.
Start singing along with it.
I loved it.
It.
That was great.
That was one of the funnest classes and
then that last one when you do,
they're quick breathing exercises on
your knees.
I looked in that mirror and I thought,
I really thought,
man,
I've had a really,
because you're out of it a little bit.
I'm like,
I've had an insane fucking journey this
morning and it's over.
I was like,
and I didn't feel like I was done in a
weird way.
Like I was like,
I'm going to do it every year.
I'm going to.
I'm doing how I'm doing that every year,
but I'm going back to hot yoga tomorrow
morning.
Yeah,
I enjoy it.
I got a guy go to,
I get,
but yeah,
I've got a bunch of classes
that I take regularly,
but I'd like a.
I like doing it at least once a week.
I feel like when I do it once a week,
it bounces me out.
I feel like that was like a very fun
class.
It sounds like you were taking.
It was the opposite of most of the
instructors are very.
You have a good,
I hate to say this,
just don't want to say without sounding
gay,
you have a good body workout,
but if you're not just long you have
like,
you have decent genetics.
If you got into Jujitsu,
Jujitsu,
his fucking yoga was impressing me.
Your ability to achieve that eagle pose
and I know it's because you have long
legs.
He goes wraparound.
The wraparound dude.
I was pretty shocked when we first
started doing it.
I was like,
everyone's going to die.
I've been doing this for awhile.
These guys are gonna feel it.
Um,
and then our is like,
I could do to twitter by the way.
One hundred percent.
That sounds just like you.
To be honest,
I really don't know what you're talking
about.
That's how far away was that when you
said like that,
that 100 percent and burt and I were
like,
he's going to the wrong class.
We had zero doubt that you were.
They were definitely not going to like.
We thought you were going to some
fucking like,
like smell the flowers.
There's no way.
He's fucking with this thing.
You can do that,
right?
See,
I cannot.
This is not happening with in Yoga.
Breathing right into this space right
here through my notes.
Just to credit whistle.
Do you ever like finger your own button
and do the best I can do?
Look at that shit.
Wow.
At least you'd get the elbow onto the
elbow.
I can't go where you are.
No posts,
Yoga Butt doing nothing but lifting
weights because I barely lifted weights
during.
It was a pretty good workout though.
It's a very good work.
That's great.
It leaned down my shoulders and my neck.
Not a ton,
but I noticed it that I was like,
oh,
I should definitely lift some weights.
Well,
you know what it's good for.
For real is your back,
your.
It's phenomenal for your spine because
you'd make.
It makes you work in ways you just not
going to do.
You're never doing that standing
airplane shit.
Standing t,
when your arms are forward,
your leg kicks back and you barely can
hold it for 10 seconds or that the Boho
point post,
Jesus Christ never do that shit.
There was a lot of people that we were
getting.
People were,
I'm going today,
I've been following you fucking assholes
for going.
And they were trying it out.
A lot of people went with us.
He came to see me.
I told them I was going to be so I can
take pictures.
So what's good about this?
Here's this good about this.
It lacked all the controversy of the
first contest.
The first contest was like a bat.
There was fucked steaks there,
steaks and has weight to lose.
And at first I thought,
well,
this one doesn't even have any fucking
stakes.
Like who cares if I don't get the 15
classes or if I sneak a little weed in,
but you know,
who cares?
You can like,
the weird thing is that we were all
doing it together and made fun of us
because every time,
every time I got on stage this weekend I
would say,
so I just finished sober October.
You would the.
I thought it'd be like saying I just
wrapped fucking star wars
eight.
Like they went in,
opened up square garden ended.
They go crazy.
They were crazy.
They went crazy and then I said it's the
dumbest fucking bed ever because there's
no god damn stakes and if you were to
finish 14 classes or drink,
then the punishment is that we would go
like,
oh,
so like you're,
you're that guy you had to host a party
for everybody else.
I really forgot about it.
Yeah,
I do remember those ice sculptures,
right?
We're supposed to get red,
yellow corvette.
That's where you for leaving.
That would have been a lot of fun.
What would it have all over it?
It was going to have things like you
think you're funny podcast or whatever.
You know,
like you want to hear a joke.
I got Joe hit me up,
I got choked.
Say need a comedian on the Camaro.
That was awesome because it was truly
the best part for me because I think I
take this a little more introspectively
at dub.
I doubled up on somewhat therapy and I
was like,
the coolest part was that I was.
I should have been honest when,
I mean in retrospect,
the next day I was like,
I should've never told them how much I
drink.
I was like,
I don't say that now,
but at that next day I was like,
oh,
this has come up bad.
Like people are going to be sad when I
drink.
But then you got john daily with like
tiger woods watching his trip stretches
his hands,
small Satchel of cash.
There was,
there was the feeling going into the
month.
To be fair was,
you know,
we're all trying to do this.
It's a challenge,
but everyone's like,
how is Bert Bert doing wholesale?
I got a lot of it about weed and we did
pray for you.
I'm going to
tell you guys that I decided like
literally last minute to forego we'd.
I decided to Disneyland.
We figured we keep pushing you up until
the 31st at midnight on the 30th at
midnight.
I bet she'll come to your senses.
So I just decided some somewhere along.
Not that Halloween that was,
it doesn't even make any sense before.
Not at Halloween.
What?
I remember what it was.
I was a dentist then.
That's what it was before October even
started,
it was like the 28th or 29th camp and I
was like,
um,
no,
that was August 11.
Will you guys go to Disneyland?
Disneyland.
So spoiled in a good way.
But we,
um,
w when I decided I wasn't gonna tell
anybody,
but I told Tom,
I told Tom like four or five days and
I'm like,
I'm not doing weed and they're talking
all this crazy shit.
Just wait,
I'm going to tell them at the end now
didn't even smoke weed.
But then all these people were
commenting and saying like,
you can't even quit weed for a month
while these guys are doing.
I was like,
all right,
this is a bad example.
Let me just come
out and say it.
So I just finished,
started talking about it.
Well that was my favorite.
I have a lot of favorites about this.
Uh,
the one was that you guys all joined in
and all gave up something and did the
challenge to,
made it fun and really took an a,
like the scope off of me.
Like everyone was like,
what can I do?
But it made it fun.
It didn't make it look like now it's
just burt not drinking.
Oh yeah.
And then my favorite part ever was when
I got that text,
I was sitting naked in bed,
criss cross applesauce.
And Ari's tech said,
get ready for your comments,
gentlemen.
We're going after Joe.
I've never gotten more excited for
those.
You who don't know.
I posted a video on my instagram that
got a lot of views and it was me jogging
through the woods.
I shot a long time ago and in it I sent
it to each of you and said,
can I green light this?
I'd like to post it.
And it said,
uh,
the machine goes sober with Joe with a
to Teddy Thompson already.
The Welsh shit for your empowerful Joe
Rogan and I was like,
gentlemen,
no weed,
no booze,
and I was like,
Joe hadn't replied.
I'm not going to post it because I
don't.
I didn't know about the weed thing.
And then Ari came out and was like,
no,
we're going after him.
Get your tax ready.
I remember being excited because I go,
this could go horribly wrong.
Joe's not the guy you want to pay into a
corner.
That's not joe in my head.
And I was like,
no,
he is.
He is one of us fucking take him down.
And he's right now.
Well yeah,
that's.
I mean I think but it's.
So we all set our texts up already
posted is me and Tom went right after it
and we watched it.
Just
you texted you motherfucker.
I never said,
oh we never did say that way.
There's like last minute you guys like
two or three days away you guys were
deciding that there was going to be no
weed and I was like,
fuck these guys.
But when I said,
fuck these guys,
man,
the response,
it was one time I was listening to the
response was like,
I can't do that.
Yeah,
it's not right.
The right thing to do is I got to quit.
We don't like that guy.
Doesn't quit any time.
Exactly.
You got to just quit.
Burt udall understand me and Joe's
medicine.
By the way,
here's this really hilarious.
I didn't have weed for the entire month,
but when Ari came to the yoga class in
Encino and I heard that he was getting
drug tests,
I was like,
okay,
you sure you didn't up pretty go into my
brain and go,
wait a minute.
When you said you said,
I'll tell you that I'll take his wheat
test if I can fucking punch him.
I said,
I'll tell him I'll take this test,
but if I'm clean,
the three of us were sitting in the
corner and like,
where's red?
It's running
late.
And I go,
I think he went to pick up drugs,
tests and Joe's face when Tommy was.
How long has this thing where I go?
I was thinking the same thing.
I was like,
yeah,
no,
I'll be clean,
but it's like,
it's like when you land,
it's like when you land in Singapore and
you're like,
I know I don't have any because they're
like,
oh yeah,
you're like,
I know I didn't bring any.
But then you start unzipping every.
Every.
Yeah.
Like in your backpack.
Yeah,
nothing.
Right?
I got nothing in here.
I don't want to.
Or like any time you pass a cop or
something like that.
Exactly what I do,
I do.
I don't take nothing by.
Here's the problem with smoking a lot of
weed.
I have a really good memory,
but I also don't.
So sometimes weird shit will happen and
I'll,
I'll go.
I didn't do that right now.
Like I get weird about like if I see a
cop and that's investigating a break in,
in the building,
I would start feeling guilty.
I'd be like,
I definitely didn't do anything,
but I don't want to make sure these guys
know I didn't do anything.
Then I'll sound guilty because I'm like,
what?
Who the fuck would rob a building these
animals out here?
Nate Society?
Those who wouldn't do that.
Yeah.
I might even say something racist if
it's a white guy.
Yeah,
sure.
I'll talk so much shit about white
people.
It feels good to Mexican fucking white
people doing.
Did you.
Was it hard at all?
What about the flooding?
You hadn't flown sober and how many
years and sober and a good a good deal.
Years.
We're not talking about at least seven.
Did not sober.
Not with like one or two tracks.
I mean like you've gotten drunk.
Oh,
flow without some sort of a neighbor.
It Shim in probably the last time I
remember doing it I was still doing laps
on limited and I had to fly back for an
audition and there was an hour flight
and I had to either give me two beers
and I held onto them in case something
happened.
I was just going to kill him and fuck
it.
I was like,
but yeah,
that was.
It wasn't just held onto two beers
during the flight.
Wow.
You were on death's door sign.
You will like Sylvester stallone in
cliffhanger with that fucking ice pick
hanging off the cliff.
What would two beers just held them in
my hands for the first flight?
Three.
That was a long time ago and I was on my
hands.
I was like,
if we start having really bad
turbulence,
I'm just going to kill him real quick
and all my anxiety will go away.
That was the first flight.
Wasn't hard.
As soon as I got home,
it was super easy.
Did you ever hold any alcohol during the
month and touch any alcohol?
Hold it in your hand.
I mean,
you didn't go.
Oh,
want a plane?
Yeah.
No,
not at all.
Wait,
how did it affect you going booze free?
Not at all.
Lost weight.
I lost weight.
I felt really good one.
It should be pounds,
right?
Then you say sugar like a motherfucker
and I could not stop eating sugar.
I'm,
I felt great.
There was no deep detox.
I just started sleeping better and then
I started feeling amazing.
Uh,
I got to tell you my biggest thing was I
was like,
I was in love with coffee.
I really started loving coffee.
So good.
It's such a treat man.
Yeah,
it is great.
just alcoholics do cigarettes and
coffee.
I have a friend and he had a little
problem with the pills and uh,
when he got off the pills he started
doing monster energy drinks.
Like motherfucker didn't mean to go.
Wait a minute.
How many of you,
you always have one in your hand.
You ever met a mountain dew addict?
I know a guy that wrote rolls around
with a two liter good,
like in,
like,
tucked into a pretty fucking high.
You know what I mean?
Like between Oh fuck.
Like a,
like a two liter.
Just rolls around with it and then it's
the next one that used to be the sign of
an alcoholic,
but 10 years ago was a red bull.
Like no one else tried red bulls.
Well you know what's crazy?
When I was a kid I worked on a
construction site and there's a guy who
was an alcoholic and he would drink out
of a mountain dew jug.
He would drink 40 ounces.
I'll take a 40 ounce and he would pour
it.
He would drink it warm all day long.
You should drink nothing.
Jeff.
I'll never forget him,
he,
I'll never forget this guy because I was
about 18 and I was just getting out of
high school and one of the guys that I
did martial arts with own a small
construction company in Dorchester,
so we'd go to this bad neighborhood.
Dorchester wasn't good and mountain dew,
Adam lived there.
He lived in this House that we were
renovating.
The House has fucked up.
It didn't have any air conditioning,
did some windows were missing.
There's a lot of open installation and
he had like a,
like a camp set up in this house and he
was also working for this construction
company that my friend on.
He had a green plastic jug mountain dew
and it was filled with four and you can
see the bubbles in it.
He just look at it and you go get this.
Definitely not fucking soda.
You saw the bubbles in it.
Let's go drink it all day and his hands
would shake,
but he would do his job.
What have you found out?
He quit and it's actually Jeff Bezos who
founded Amazon,
figured it out,
figured it out.
Nobody got ahold of an Anthony Robbins
cassette,
fucking get his life together.
Went to a kyle cease seminar.
Oh yeah.
Sparks coming out of his finger on it.
No,
I had a word for DTS.
None.
Everyone was worried you're going to
die.
That was a.
But your blood pressure drops
substantially,
right?
Yeah.
And I and I kind of fell in love with
being sober again,
like,
have like of like how much is it feels
good to just drive around and just go.
I'm totally clear headed and I'm not
going like,
ah,
fucking beat man.
I'm hung over.
I need a coffee just to get to the other
side of the hill.
Just wake up and go.
Maybe I'll stop at the top of the hill
and go for a ride on a hike on runyon.
Yeah.
It was like really great flying sobers
changed my life.
Although I didn't do it on my flight
back from New Orleans who did trunks.
I had like four or five drinks,
but.
But that was only because I've got way
too fucked up on that cruise.
You know,
Melissa Etheridge,
she doesn't think that she could ever be
in a car wreck or a plane crash.
Why she thinks that
she knows is it creates a reality with
her mind and she gets on a plane and she
says,
these people are so lucky on the plane
with me because I'll never be in a plane
crash.
Oh Wow.
I'm that way with AIDS different.
Unless you wanted to.
The new terrorism.
If some dude running down the street
with a needle just to fucking score at
nate's and it will most likely if you
stay away from needles and weird gay
sex,
you're not going to get to aids.
Probably that.
But like you could play in crashes.
You can't control plane crash.
No.
That's so dumb.
It's not even like,
what is she talking about?
Well,
it's based on the same thing that the
secret and all that law of attraction
steps based on it's based on success.
Yeah,
but,
but the problem with that,
just being delusional.
But the problem with that is,
you know,
the problem with that is you're only
talking to the people that are
successful.
There's a lot of people that have
similar ideas and they weren't
successful,
so you only,
it's you're,
you're dealing with a very shitty
control group,
right?
Because you're only going.
It's not scientific.
You're only going to the people that
were successful.
You talked to someone who just has
perfect features.
Talked to Angelina Jolie.
How do you get so lucky?
Why is it pretty?
Well,
I was in another dimension and I
imagined it.
Bitch,
you got lucky.
She's got bell's palsy right now.
Really?
So half her face is frozen.
From what stress?
From Bradley Benner and her raising six
kids,
whatever.
She got just got bell's palsy,
Bell's Palsy.
You get that stressed.
Are you friends with Harvey Levin?
No,
no,
I saw.
I saw it somewhere.
I'm obsessed with bell's palsy because
I'm always afraid I'll get it before I
shoot something big and then just like,
sorry.
It's the teacher that had had it for a
couple of weeks.
Thrill.
Yeah,
it's great.
It's great.
Do you ever think you'll get to a point
where you realize you're successful
enough where you could just relax or do
you always think you're always going to
be in this place where you're like,
boy,
I hope nothing happens to me before this
bell's palsy.
Yeah,
like I hope.
I hope I don't get sick before this big
thing happens because the thing is
always right around the corner.
Like what if the thing.
What if you got to a point where you
like Ron White,
right?
We were talking about Rama for the
podcast.
I'll funny.
Is Ron White still 60?
Killing it,
selling out 6,000
seat arena is just killing it,
you know?
Do you think he'd relaxed like Ron Ron
doesn't give,
couldn't be wrong.
I really couldn't be running.
Follow Ron on periscope.
He doesn't give up.
He really genuinely doesn't give a fuck
and I wish I could be more that way.
I would like he,
he came in to do.
When I did a podcast with him,
he came in and smoking a joint,
smoked it through the entire Bible self,
but not in a rude way.
He spoke the entire joint and then said,
oh,
I forgot you're a drinker.
And then we started drinking Tequila and
now in my head I'm like,
my day's wrapped.
I just drank half a bottle of Tequila
with Ron White.
I'm going to go home and celebrate.
And I was like,
so what are you doing tonight?
And he's like,
I went with the store and I was like,
I could never go to the store that
fucked up,
like.
And he was totally fine,
but I see him on periscope and he'll
just be smoking joints and drinking and
just loving life.
I,
I can never be that.
Um.
In what way?
Why can't you be that?
What do you mean?
I don't like going on stage drunk.
I don't like being out of control
onstage.
But what about,
what about the part of like being
content or do you mean like isn't that
what the question was?
Can never be component is not a matter
of content.
It's a matter about worrying about
potential horrible things happening to
you because you're so insecure about the
future.
Wow.
That's so a wet because I believe that
my,
My worrying I'm sofa sets up scenarios
for me to avoid those problems.
That's a good point of view.
So I was legit.
I worry about a lot of things.
Like when I go to do radio I worry about
like what if they asked me this and I
get myself prepared for it and in a lot
of times it's for nothing and I think
about it,
but my point.
When you say,
are you saying like when you go into
radio,
you're worried that they're going to set
you up,
are they going to be mean to you or
something or maybe it's not always not
always be prepared for the onset can do
that.
Right.
I always prepare for the onside kick.
I mean
it's like a once in a couple of times
over the year or something.
We try it or it's not that common.
It's a last minute attempt so it's
basically where the incident happened
once.
It's not gonna happen to every game.
It's either surprise move what you're
doing once a year or it's like you need
the ball back,
you have 10 seconds left as it's a way
to kick to the other team,
but you can get,
let's say very short and you get the
ball back.
A martial arts comparison.
So question mark kick.
No,
it's more like the one that Miyaki
taught.
What's his name?
Daniel like front kick.
That's only happened once.
Yeah,
Leo Machida.
He did that exact kit really knocked
out.
Randy coture,
the grandkids.
He literally did the exact same kick.
He just put his arms in the air,
but Duane Ludwig did put his arms in the
air and King of the cage and Ken Smith,
he was beating the fuck out of this poor
dude.
This is old school when you were
wrestling shoes.
So Shad Smith was wearing wrestling.
She,
Chad Smith,
who eventually became the first openly
gay MMA fighter article about him in New
York Times.
A very interesting like super honest
article.
Very interesting stuff,
but he fought dwayne.
He had no business being in the cage
with Dwayne.
It was the early days of MMA.
People hadn't realized that Dwayne was a
boss route and student super technical
striker,
one of the best striking coaches like
today,
like just he coached Tj dillashaw won
the bantamweight title on Saturday
night.
Yeah,
but Dwayne,
fuck this dude up.
Dwayne was on like a way higher level in
and these guys were used to in the
middle of the fight.
He stood there and put his.
Did the crane kick and the guy walked
into it.
Well look,
there's,
there's Dwayne.
He was just,
he was beating the fuck out this guy so
bad that he could have done anything to
him.
See if he could play the fight.
Oh my God.
It was fine to go for it.
It's just,
it's it preposterous.
How bad he beat the students at Duke
Ellington Beach.
Yeah.
He was like skateboarding with those
shoes on.
I mean,
it was ridiculous.
The Guy who's the other guy that's
chance fans.
Yup.
He has.
I forgot.
Crazy fancy laces.
Yeah,
but look at the beating.
Look at this.
I mean,
it's just so wrong.
This is done already.
So dwayne.
So technically he's never in a position
where he could do anything to him.
Like right there,
that combination man,
this art that left hook to the body,
right?
Low kick.
That's about as classical Moitai
combinations.
You'd get such a small cage to.
But in the middle of the fight,
Dwayne did that.
He plays.
He's like pitch,
I got you.
Yeah.
Are there extend that analogy than just
don't prepare for the onside kick or a
great fighters?
Or is there a fighter that doesn't look
at every option?
Because I believe there's a lot of
factors.
I look if I figure if you.
I do that with material where if you
just look at every angle and just kind
of obsessive compulsively tear it apart,
then you're never going to be some
surprise.
And when you are surprised it's you
won't get hurt.
Yes.
And there's no right?
Because there's factors when it comes to
fighting.
And then this factor is if you made the
analogy for comedy that you wouldn't
apply to joe ideas.
Like one of the things about Joey Diaz
is Julie Diaz just going off the cuff
like a good 60 percent of the time and
he has all these ideas that he can go
off the cuff from,
but so it would almost be like
preparation for joey would be like
detrimental.
Like he prep prepares a certain amount
but that off the cuff has got.
He's got to live in that moment.
That's why you got to see Joey Diaz live
and he's like living in that moment.
Nothing like it.
And it's.
And it's also almost like,
I think his best shit is like hanging
around with him.
Who knows you love him.
Like Tommy when you and I did that
podcast with him when we did the
thousandth episode and the three of us,
we were Tommy and I couldn't breathe,
couldn't talk.
We had a stop.
We were both leaning.
Oh,
under the table.
Their sides.
Well Joey was just crushing and it,
you can't,
you can't write that down.
When they did,
you couldn't plan it out.
You couldn't take.
I can't take it to the stage.
He's got to just,
he's does it in his way and like there's
like there's a lot of power in that too,
so like there's a power in like a guy
who has unbelievable athleticism and
power,
like a rampage.
Jackson who just hit was so powerful.
Rampage and his prime was so goddamn
powerful.
And then there's a pen like super
technical and like which one's better
but depends.
Well,
I wouldn't say I'm texting by any
stretch of the means in any part of my
life.
That's a little bit that it's a
technique to observing your comedy,
like to going over your material.
I think I consider it to be a very
technical thing that over the last like
four or five years I've taken it
progressively more and more serious
where I force myself to listen to
recordings of forced myself to write
bits out and consider all the different
aspects of writing them out and then
consider them as I'm saying them
onstage.
I never did that before.
I never did that to about four or five
years ago.
I would write occasionally.
That's what I did until about four or
five years ago.
I would record my sets and I would write
a case.
You become more technical.
Yeah,
it's,
it's.
It is technical,
but I'm never going to be as funny as
joey ideas.
Do you know what I'm saying?
Like those moments that he hits,
they're different.
They're different.
There's a different kind of moment and
it's a.
it's not a planned out moment.
Oh,
Susie says,
let me tell you something though.
That's when I.
that's when I wake up.
Joey would get mad not at me,
but about things to me that it wasn't
even arguing,
yelling at you just to get ready to go
onstage.
So you'd be backstage with these fucking
guys with that fucking up comedy rooms.
What the fuck is all,
get so fired up.
Who you fucking Momos with your glasses
and your old school.
Fucking lace up boots.
Get the fuck Outta here.
And he was just like anybody was saying
to him.
Then he would take that,
just run onto the stage and he was just
still on there already.
Fucking beat it up.
He would do that to us all the time.
Remember the green room calls when he
calls you,
like people are like,
hello?
I'll be tell you one thing.
She yelled at me at the Improv.
Once we're bringing a notebook that's
going to let everybody know.
You're right.
You got to fucking know Poco via Joe
Rogan.
You're like one of those fucking guys
who can't let me bring my notebook on
stage and tell the same fucking
material.
I have a talent for five fucking years.
He just went right to the stage.
I told you what happened with Joey and
my dad on that plane.
Plane.
They flew together.
Yeah.
My Dad flew with Joey.
No.
Really?
So yeah,
my dad gets.
My Dad loves joey loves joey certain
Tampa.
Joey's doing Tampa.
My dad gets on the plane and Joey's
eating space cake and he goes,
Oh,
I'm Mr Kang.
You want one of my cookie dough is
already dose my dad before my dad twice.
My Dad's like,
no,
I'm good joey.
So my dad sits on the flight.
He lands and he texted me and he says,
Joey d's on my flight.
We should.
Maybe we should give him a ride home
except with joey and I lived next door
to each other near each other.
So my dad,
my dad gets off the plane and he goes,
uh.
He goes,
I said,
I was a flight.
He goes,
ah,
it was great.
I was looking at Joey.
Joe was out the whole fucking flight.
He sucked.
I said,
what about your fighting goes?
I sat next to a god damned moron.
And I said,
really?
It was a fucking more I can tell you
this.
He,
I slept next to a fucking moron.
I'm a moron.
Bird.
Guy's ripped muscles.
But the dumbest human being I could ever
sit next to.
I said,
why?
And he goes,
five hours.
He played candy crush.
He's a grown man.
Five hours.
You played candy crush.
I mean,
you'd think he'd have a thought that
he'd write down or want to lift up a
paper.
But for five hours he played fucking
candy crush.
Joey Diaz comes out around the corner of
the airport and goes,
dog.
Your Dad sat next to John Cena.
You play candy crush the whole fucking
flight.
Oh my poor John Sienna plays candy
crush.
You just kind of out fucking five hours.
I've done it.
I don't fuck with those games man.
I don't fight with those games.
Cause depression.
You're talking about that?
Yeah.
My wife's got a problem with that subway
surfer one.
I watch her play and seeing all the
time.
No,
there's too many crazy games out there
and you know,
razor,
you know the company that makes gaming
peripherals,
they have a fucking razor now has a
phone,
a gaming phone.
All those games with crazy large
speakers on the sides of it.
So like it as bezels that have like
these speakers with base.
It has a giant battery where it'll
fucking play video games forever and
you're just going to be a stone cold on
your phone.
Oh,
did it digitally?
And it's good.
One hundred and 20 frames per second.
The refresh rate is like way above,
like double what a regular phone is.
Magical.
It is lost in those fucking angry birds.
Birds.
That was a tough one.
That's crazy.
Birds if you're in London,
if you're doing coke in London,
you're fucking crazy.
Crazy.
But that's find out that girl.
Oh,
never mind.
I shouldn't say that.
Don't say good cold brew.
So who had the craziest dreams do we do?
We all have crazy doing crazy dreams at
this five days.
At this time,
lucy,
it's like eight days for lack of a weed.
It was like almost immediately for me.
Maybe it's because of the two or three
days.
Really.
Two or three days.
No,
we'd get dreams,
but I didn't have much weed before then
I kind of tapered off the last week and
then two or three days with no weed and
I was having fucking primal dreams.
Really?
Wolves chasing me cave.
There was a giant blonde,
like a light brown bear and it was with
a baby and they noticed me and I was
realizing it was going to chase me out
of the cave.
Super realistic,
like terrifying,
super realistic,
Super Realistic Wolf Dreams.
Wolves with extra large pause.
They will like these big wolves that
could run in snow because their paws
were extra large.
They'd like snow shoe pause and I was
stuck trying to run away from wolves.
Do.
Is that your.
Is that your go to animal that kind of
let you know that Shit's going on in
your life?
I've always been obsessed with
Werewolf's ever since I was a little kid
because I've always felt like what a
wearable represents is like obviously
it's like a fun fake movie monster,
but also the idea behind it is like
everybody is normal and calm.
Like in most circumstances,
most circumstances you're talking to
people and they're like us just hanging
out,
having a good time talking for the most
part,
but we all know that shit could go
horribly,
horribly wrong,
and when shit goes horribly,
whether it's like that church massacre
in Texas or whether it's a fucking bear
chasing you,
things go primal and they go to some
place where you,
you,
you.
If you want to survive,
you have to.
You have to behave in a way that you are
very uncomfortable with.
Like if someone's trying to kill you and
they have a knife and you grab their
wrist and you know that that knife is
going to your chest,
you're going to get to a primal,
terrifying place where you can shove a
knife in someone's neck and cut their
throat open because you know they were
trying to kill you.
Sure.
That's when the wolf comes out and for
whatever reason,
the lack of weed made me go,
Whoa,
grave wolf does like the weed keeps the
wolf at bay.
That's awesome.
That's great.
Keeps a wolf at bay.
In my mind,
I'm realizing now the more I talked to
psychologists and people understand
neurochemistry,
like my developmental process of going
through high school fighting was super
bad for farm.
It worked out really well as far as we
can be compensated for UFC belt.
Great.
Fucking devcon three all day long.
Trying to calm it down.
I'm always at defcon three,
like growing up,
getting kicked and punched and anger on
alert.
It's not just that.
It's like your brain expresses itself in
a different way because it's like I had
violence,
violence.
No violence.
Big Cut off,
no more violence and there was no
violence.
Like someone coming home from war in a
way.
It's super similar in a way that I
didn't recognize your.
I literally,
literally till I started smoking weed
and then I didn't stop fucking almost 20
years.
No,
20 from three.
I'm 50 from 30 to 50.
It's almost all weed.
Once Eddie Bravo turned me onto weed,
I was off to the races because window.
That was like how long?
When I was 30.
Really?
That's what the last,
it was 1998.
Nineteen 98.
Eddie Bravo and I became friends.
That's when I started training John John
to take you a year for you to go like,
all right,
I'll try this stuff right away.
But when you win at being pitched to you
right away or you were like no one has a
crazy way of pitching things as you
know.
Eddie gets very excited about that.
But um,
that was,
he was more reserved and his ideas
because I don't think he believed in his
ideas as much,
but he believed in weed.
You know what I mean by that is like,
like I had to tell eddie that he was a
genius.
I was like,
dude,
you're a jujitsu genius.
Like I've been around martial arts my
whole life.
I'm like,
you're like a prodigy.
Like you know,
Shit,
you see things other people don't see.
It was like,
you're crazy.
And then we choked out.
Heuler Gracie in Brazil and I was like,
I fucking told you bitch fucking good at
this.
Oh,
you knew him during that time,
yo.
Yeah man.
I went with him to Brazil in 2003.
That's crazy.
But from then till now it was like
pretty much all wheat and it changed the
way I think about things because it
makes you more affectionate.
It makes you more compassionate,
it calms you,
it calms you down.
And then from all the talks with
psychologists and neurologists and all
these neuroscientists,
you realize like the other pathways that
are formed during your developmental
period and one of the big ones is the
period between 15 and 25 because when
you're 25,
that's when your frontal cortex is
supposedly formed.
When all your experiences and all of
your genetics,
they all come together and kind of
formed who you are to the point where
we've all decided like this is the time
where Tom at 25 can be rational,
whereas before you're dealing with so
much,
there's so much of your consciousness is
in development.
So much of your opinions on life are
distorted by your environment and your
ability to discern objectively what you
should and shouldn't do isn't quite in
place yet,
and neurotic neuroscientists believe
that that takes place according to the
people that I've met,
somewhere around 25,
so for me for like 15 to 21,
22,
it was chaos.
It was all chaos.
It was all head kicks and getting your
bell wronged and watching people go
unconscious.
It was all chaos because that's all I
did.
That's all I did from like 15 to 21 and
then so like this and so this says,
put that in perspective.
Joy.
I remember the first time I watched
someone get knocked unconscious and that
was traumatic for me.
Dude,
I've seen.
I've seen people get fucked up.
Think about it.
I've called more than a thousand.
See events more than a thousand.
Really more than a thousand.
More than 1000.
So have people seen people give up?
Yeah,
for sure.
All the nones.
So you've probably seen like $3,000
fights at least apply for the fights.
Fights?
No,
no,
not.
Well there's only UFC two to 70 a
thousand contests between individuals,
you know,
thousand individual.
Easily.
Easily fights.
So you got to think 10 fights for 100
cards.
That's a thousand.
I've done more than that.
It feels like you would live on high
alert.
Not Good.
Always like keeping an eye on her head
once she was taken something out of the
back of the car as the hatch.
And the thing came down.
Now the accident that come down ended up
point,
got her right in the fucking head and
she was bleeding like blood was pouring
down her head.
I got a real problem with injuries,
man.
I go,
that's nothing.
Oh really?
I'm like,
that's not shit.
This is a little tiny cuts.
Only like an inch long.
Like my thought is,
unless it's catastrophic.
Yeah,
you're fine.
Keep your arms broke.
I'm like,
ah,
you got to go to the doctor,
but this little cut.
I'm like,
that's nothing.
And I'm like,
what the fuck is wrong with me?
There's blood pouring down her head and
I've already like.
Just like,
like I'm doing triage.
Like what the possibility,
what's the worst thing that can deal
with it?
Deal with the worst thing can happen
with this ain't the worst thing.
We're good.
I wish I had that.
No one's bones are poking through the
skin way too comfortable with trauma.
Way Too comfortable,
not good,
not good to see hundreds of dudes get
knocked the fuck out.
Right?
Which is similar toward like to create
the parallel is like people who have
seen obviously really horrific,
but that's wages.
It's different,
but there's a similarity because they
see,
they see people you know,
killed or maimed,
and then so when you go like this hurts,
they're like,
you're fine,
you're fine.
Well,
that's why it's answer ever talked to.
I had that lady on who won the Moab to
Flores.
Courtney Walter.
She's amazing.
She's a monster.
By more than 10 hours,
10 hours to get into a zone that she
couldn't even see anyone around her.
She couldn't even be like the head of
that.
She's like,
there's nobody around me.
Even crazier.
She won a race while she was 90 percent
blind,
90 percent blonde.
She some sort of cerebral or a retinal
edema or corneal edema during this
happened.
During one of her races,
not this one,
but another one,
but this was another crazy long one.
And She just kept going.
Yes,
she won and she fell.
Bust her head open.
She had a huge gash in her head.
Blood pouring down her face.
She barely could see each stitch.
You could only see her feet.
She didn't know where she was going.
She was like literally running while her
contact lenses had some sort of a
reaction with her eyes and she could not
fucking see.
And she still won.
So when you talk about like tough,
like you like to think I can fucking
take it.
No,
no,
no.
She can take it.
Yeah,
I don't.
I don't know how the human.
We're complaining about 15 yoga class.
I know that's crazy,
but very hard.
She could do it all at once.
We had to like the whole month,
but I'm telling you like the people,
like people like her can go into a state
of mind that we don't understand because
that's how long did she do?
What is it?
Forty eight hours or less?
No more than 50.
So she,
she wants you to realize she could do
it.
And what is it like 58.
Less than 58.
She realized like it would be 58 hours
though.
She completed 240 miles.
Two hundred.
Three official minutes of sleeping.
She just tried to lay down for 20
minutes and she couldn't fall asleep or
mind was racing and then she took a one
minute nap and popped open toe shoes and
the guy was like,
she was stumbling,
zigzagging across the road.
She could barely stay awake.
And the guy that was keeping pace where
they're like,
people will jump in the race and keep
pace with you for like 10 miles at a
stretch.
That makes sense.
So when this guy was keeping pace with
it,
I was like,
you know,
he's like,
if you want to take a nap,
she goes,
okay,
you got to wake me up in one minute.
You Go,
okay,
one minute.
So he wakes her up in one minute and she
was good to go and she kept going.
She said,
one minute she had amazing sleep.
She woke up,
she felt refreshed.
She couldn't.
She was mad at him because she couldn't
believe he let her sleep.
He goes,
I let you sleep for one minute.
She's like,
okay,
great.
I feel like the FBI needs to fucking
talk to her earlier.
And she eats Nacho Cheese,
candy candy when she was here.
She is a hero to my new hero because
her,
her.
It's her fucking mind,
dude.
It's amazing.
There's no other way.
When you fall,
when you're half blind and you hit your
head and you're bleeding,
it's so easy
to quit.
She won't quit.
Excuse now.
Won't quit.
Is understandable not to wear shirt
stream by.
Do understand people that go,
I just got to finish it,
but not to her extreme.
That's insane.
I think at a certain point I go,
my vision is more important than this
race.
So you would barely be behind her.
It'd be like her.
Yeah.
You would have been like,
I think so.
I got to be on her heels a lot,
a lot of catch up and I'm running a half
marathon on the 19th of November.
We'll find out very the little.
No training.
You like injuries?
I won't get injured.
I'll be fine.
Mickey Mantle over here in Tampa on the
19th after I do my weekend at the Improv
Irvine this weekend.
Everybody's slow.
Drunk guys are going to pull you from
the trail and lick you in the woods.
You're the hero of drunk man.
You're the hero of drunk men.
You are just a lot of people love you.
Tell you for numerous reasons on the
cruise he got drunk,
hard and a casino and it was the life of
the party on just shared over the head.
I thought that's sort of a kind of
performance that I don't do.
And you don't do.
No,
I know and you don't do either,
please.
So it's like in trying to get you to
conform to a life of no drinking.
Are we removing some of the great
classic American Drunken Theater?
Berta too.
It's not just that like why do we always
think,
why do we always think of performances?
And I'm not saying that you're
performing like you,
like,
like you need attention.
It's not that it's in you,
right?
It comes out when everybody's drinking,
you're having a good time.
It's not nothing negative about it,
but why?
Why do we classify that as being
different than things that are
entertaining that we go to see?
Right.
Like if you go to see someone to stand
up,
you expect it to be funny.
If you go to class,
go to.
If you go to see someone in a movie,
you expect them to be funny.
But part of what being funny is is like
being able to be funny.
Like you're being funny.
You're,
you're a fucking performances.
Like when we're drunk at a bar,
those are legit.
Totally.
Those are the most fun thing to.
To be around it.
And it's sort of a piece of art is what
I'm saying.
And you got to have a piece of art very
enjoyable,
knows what it's like going to him.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
Oh,
thank you for managing the room too.
You manage the room,
you bring.
It's authentic.
It's who you are.
You really should just live at a bar.
They got to come up with a pill that
makes alcohol not bad or a new alcohol
is.
The problem is when I heard that your
blood pressure drops substantially.
I was like,
wow,
all I can think of in a bad way.
It was like,
what?
What would happen if you continue the
way you did?
And we didn't do the sober October thing
and he just dealing with metro medical
solutions to this.
Are you quitting booze for
a month?
Dropped your blood pressure by what?
How many points was it 150,000
points.
That's $200,000.
Record because you weighed 3:35
when we started this.
Three d,
if he was a pan to you,
have you know what the good thing is for
you though,
for real?
Is that even though you were like,
I know I can,
you know for sure.
You have no doubt that if you had to
stop drinking for any period of time,
you can do it.
He's not addicted.
You're not.
I think I talked to Dr drew and Bob
Forest about it.
Well two good experts definitely don't
talk to a real doctors and they were
like,
we need to go to someone who does like
actual research.
But no,
they uh,
yeah,
I,
it was just.
No disrespect.
I don't even know who the second guy is.
He's said he was on a celebrity reader
app for science.
He was a,
he was,
he was an,
he was spit on it.
No celebrity rehab.
Oh my God.
Stan hope went in deep hard in the paint
on Dr.
Oh,
I love Dr drew.
But he deserved.
It doesn't like it.
Well,
it's not real,
you know,
that's not the way it's supposed to be.
Healing people with cameras on their
face.
It's nice.
It's not good for the APP,
it's not good for the actors or the
musicians or whoever.
It's not good for anybody.
It's not good for people that are trying
to understand what their diseases to see
each other mock like that and having
these mock arguments with each other and
having these survivors forced inner.
Yeah,
well there's two cameras and two people
arguing by the pool and insulting each
other.
Other's plastic surgery and failures and
all other divorces to.
We set this soda
now what I like when we started,
we were having so much fun with this
Aria and I think were talking on the
phone and he was like,
uh,
he was like,
this should be a TV show,
but then he's like,
immediately all the authenticity would
be removed out of this competition if we
did these competitions there are so
genuine and we do get to put them out in
media for our fans to listen to.
But if you did it with a camera crew
front of you would never be real.
It would never be as
be on a time limit.
Like you have to specifically check in
now instead of like Australia,
oh look at this.
Photoshop pulling it.
Also,
part of the,
what I think the experience was amazing
was that we were all like tune.
We're all locked into a task together
and took a buddy on new and.
But there was no official thing to it,
so we all put posted did number six
today,
yoga down would make little videos see
you,
but it was like photoshops by the way
off the level of photoshop level.
We have to credit those guys.
I screened saved some of them.
I was going to do a montage of
photoshop,
massage,
erotic pandas,
erratic podcast,
all praise.
I'll praise to all those peoples.
Just did a one offs.
There were some great one offs that dose
that kills it.
Then they just kept doing.
They were like,
oh.
I was like,
I would like to get online because
anyone can say that,
oh,
it's got to cross reference your
instagrams.
Like nobody's gotten there yet.
You killed it too.
I think doing stuff like this is good
for people that are listening to it's.
I think it's definitely good for us,
but I think it's good for people
listening to because I think doing
something where you all can like joining
with your friends and have a task gray
either.
It's good for you.
I got a Lamborghini.
I thought you had that new called me in
advance.
I didn't call you.
You at the store.
That's what happened.
Oh,
that's right.
You told me at the store I was going to
try.
I called you when I saw you in front of
us.
Right?
I saw the Lamborghini.
I'm like,
it's got to be Tom.
Best thing,
like the whole thing was.
So I was gonna try to get the three of
you try to fool the three of you and
then then I was going to go.
I was like,
I'm going to go to the store tonight in
it just to see if the rumor was started
spreading,
you know,
and then.
But then it was like not a bad idea for
your car when I went in and I was like,
Tom's not here yet.
No.
Well the thing is I didn't bring it.
I was like,
no,
that'll ruin having it at yoga.
Right.
So then I go,
it happens that you're all three there.
I'm like,
well that's good.
I didn't bring it because then they
would have seen it here.
It would have been a thing.
So then I'm going to leave and as I'm
leaving,
you know when you're excited,
like you're excited about a new joke.
Like I said,
he's like,
what's up?
I was like,
I'm bringing a Lamborghini and I start.
I tell them and I go,
you got to back me up.
He goes,
fuck you.
I'll tell him
Bali.
I was like,
that's perfect,
so bad.
Why did you keep it here?
That was the dream.
The dream
was that the next day I wouldn't reveal
it.
And then you pull it into Mazda,
right of the store and look,
I'm like,
this shit wasn't real.
And you're like,
oh shit,
it's fucking morons.
The hardest actually
was second hand comment because the
whole thing was just to try to get bird.
I just wanted to get burned and there
was a time,
by the way,
when you got in your car and you are
towards birds car,
I turned.
I was backing up in that car and it's
really nice.
See?
He's like,
oh,
Lamborghini
that much.
I was like,
you still got $40,000
off so.
But yeah,
it's still $260,000.
Still a lot of money.
So we started figuring out how much
money you made the year.
I know,
I know how much money you make.
Oh,
based on like just conjecture.
And you're telling me,
telling already that we started trying
to figure out how much,
how many weeks you'd have to work to
earn that car?
Yeah.
Well this is the best part.
When.
So I,
I go,
I return it,
right?
I get,
I make a video with the guy go,
I'm going to hold this.
He was super nice guy.
He knew about the challenge and
everything and I go,
I'm going to video vertical.
And like what?
The brains blown out,
the brains blown out,
complaining about the trunk space,
which is a nice feature that barely fit
in the fucking
no room,
but the best part was that when I post,
I posted it before class number 15.
I posted it and I'm going to take class
and then when I come out I'll get
comments in August,
so I talked to Bert and he goes,
he was like,
you fucking Dick.
Like I knew you wouldn't be that stupid
to buy that.
And I go.
He goes,
oh,
sorry,
I thought you bought it because you're
white trash from Florida
arms folded.
Stopped Riding Shotgun Down Ventura.
He's an idiot.
I mean,
this makes sense.
Makes total sense.
What drives from Florida white trash not
being that guy.
The best part is that like
having lived in Florida for so long,
like that analogy is that announces is
perfect.
Like if you go like if somebody is like
driving a Lamborghini and you go that
guy from Florida,
Oh yeah,
definitely has that.
Genie is a Florida.
Florida guys wins the fucking mega
millions.
He's getting a Lamborghini Florida six
tickets right here.
I laid in bed that night and I was
googling a barber's Harley barbers.
It's a bike I want.
It's just stripped down kind of chopper,
but it's cool.
Look in detail at the end.
I think they respond to you guys without
lying to try to figure out what I said.
Like when you asked me did Tommy really
get a Lamborghini?
What did I say?
I said something to you.
I fucking danced it like a lawyer
thing was I told you he posted all these
pictures of me in the video but didn't
post my reveal like my room
trouble ever again so I can get on
stage.
I start talking about it and everyone's.
Everyone's laughing at all the setup
stuff and then I go and then I got,
I rented this Lamborghini and there's
like a,
Oh,
when people meet me afterwards and they
go,
I can't believe you're going to have a
Lamborghini.
Oh,
the other best part was this for that
class.
Right before I posted the video.
I'm talking to burt on the phone and
we're talking about like just
authenticity and people
in your perception of them and like how
you,
how you value relationships.
And I go,
I hope you'll never see me differently
just because I have a Lamborghini.
And he goes,
no,
I think it's awesome.
Barbara,
you have to catch up.
No,
hold on.
no,
no.
Joe,
I'm not buying a lambo.
I just have a conversation in my head.
You got to get on the board before how
that makes you at least have to get into
the C or d position.
You're not going to be a.
you're not going to be beat,
but I'm a barber gets you in like deer
ego.
Mind you.
I.
Hold on.
Let's just keep things real and cut me
off if you want me to start,
but like a come over here.
We do a podcast.
I see the new place.
I go,
wow,
Joe's got some treats and I go and you
get a lambo and I go,
Tommy's got some treats.
How you treat,
treat,
treat yourself a little cup.
So I'm laying in bed.
I have a fucked up reward system.
I agree,
but I'm.
I'm googling them and treat.
Did she see you?
She sees you is what are you doing?
I said,
I'm looking at a street motorcycles,
and she goes,
we can't afford that right now.
And I go,
the adult say that I go,
I can afford whatever the fuck I want to
in a pool.
And I go,
hey grant,
it's not 300 fucking thousand dollars
going,
whoa,
whoa.
No.
I go because you had gotten the porch
first,
you know,
like treat yourself.
Got to tell you the surprising part,
the surprising part of it because.
Oh,
because do you remember the look on my
face when he,
when he.
But it wasn't,
it wasn't healthy.
No,
it wasn't.
It wasn't files your shrink.
I was like,
hold on.
What's happening to us?
Like what's happening to Tom?
You said you kept saying what's
happening?
What's happening to us?
The first time he told me he sought out
the truck and he sold out like six
fucking shows.
I remember.
Do you remember me?
I was silent on the phone going,
that's amazing.
Like what's happening,
like what's possible,
like Holy Shit,
I didn't think that was possible for
guys like me and you.
So then when I saw that I was like,
I was like,
wait,
well here's the important thing that
already said it earlier when he was
telling you to go after me.
He's like,
he's no different.
He's one of us.
That's 100 percent.
We're all the same.
Yes.
No,
anybody who tells you any different is
lying to you.
We're all the same.
Everybody that gets onstage and tells
jokes is the same.
How far you get through the maze has
zero bearing on whether or not you're a
real comic.
So if you see Tom doing it,
you could do it too.
That thing that keeps you worried about
bell's palsy is the same thing that
keeps you freaking out about like
whether or not your real.
It's all the same thing.
Same thing.
So when you see him get something like I
got to get something to,
I've got to get a reward to show that.
I'm like right here.
You have to keep up with it.
But it's like everyone's getting
presence.
It's the same thing.
You're only doing it because he has.
If he had,
you're right.
It had,
if he had not shown up with a fucking
Lamborghini to yoga class motorcycle
2017.
Who had I done?
Oh my God,
this is the part I didn't expect.
Which was the part that was not thought
about in the prank.
The whole thing was just like,
just get to go.
What happened was all the people,
because you know,
comments can be like sad,
like,
you know,
everything is like fuck you or whatever.
Like you know,
it can be really negative.
Can Be for sure.
I can't,
I can't tell you how many people were
like happy for you man.
That's awesome.
Like you deserve it.
Why?
And
then some people were like,
really lost the fan.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Because you got.
And I was like,
what?
A lot of fans.
I lose three or four a day.
Yeah,
sure you're right.
But people were genuinely happy like you
are done with me.
I really think and I really think
there's so many hours.
Have you been a nice guy that people
understand you're a nice guy,
really did do get it and they get your
sense of humor and so when you.
If you bought a Lamborghini like toms,
I guess I didn't expect it.
It's horrible,
man.
I don't think there's been very many of
those in the world.
I don't think there's been very,
very many of those like environments
where someone can do something that
makes other people happy over long
periods of time,
like a podcast and they get to know you
and then they see you.
I mean,
dude,
when I first met you was in Phoenix in
like 2007.
When did that?
Charlie Murphy Real men of comedy and we
did that Phoenix theater in the round.
That's right.
And you were living in east La.
It was a super scary neighborhood.
You are gunshots.
I remember you and I talking.
I'm like,
Damn,
I hope Tommy makes it.
Became friends.
We're going to want you to die.
We started doing the road.
I mean,
dude,
we started doing the road together and
like probably 2007 or eight.
We did a bunch of gigs together,
so.
So to see you struggling from then to
killing it now and then doing all these
podcasts in between,
I'm not alone like I've done this with
millions of other people that have
watched you as well,
so if they know you and they like you,
they they want to leave.
A positive comment was a nice surprise.
I mean I just,
it's just a part of it.
I didn't.
I thought people were all going to be
like,
you're a fucking piece of shit.
Which there were a few,
but most people,
the majority of the comments were like
way to go.
Way to go.
That's so great.
That's possible,
man.
It's all possible.
The reason why people get aggressive and
angry because they feel like they're on
the outside.
They feel like they can never get
inside.
They're angry.
They're on the outside.
We're all on the inside.
It's like a perception that keeps you on
the outside.
Yeah,
that's true.
It's all perception and to this day I.
Every time I,
my name gets like,
like ladies and gentleman,
Joe Rogan.
I fucking go,
what are you even doing?
You even know what the fuck you're doing
like to this day.
So he didn't let us in is pretty nuts
to.
Doesn't seem right.
It didn't seem.
It was a stage.
I did the theater at Madison Square
Gardens.
It's like 6,000
people.
It's insane.
It feels so scary.
Like before you're about to understand
how we hear first time you told me you
did a 6,000
seater and you're like,
I was in a traffic jam and I said to the
driver what's all this traffic for?
And he was like,
oh,
there's a big show of it was me and Tony
Hinchcliffe and Ian Edwards.
We're headed to this,
this big giant ass fucking theater
Dallas,
6,000
seats and as we're pulling up a god damn
fucking traffic and then we realized we
were stuck in my traffic.
This is nerve wracking,
but don't you a nine slash 11 of comedy?
It's not.
It's nerve wracking,
but I think the reason I am the way I am
with a little bit of all unimpressed,
like on both of those stories,
would you rather me be real in those
moments that are like,
what the hell?
Oh No.
Let me get one of those.
Give me two years.
$10,000
off.
Better than bigger than Louis in five
years for sure.
No,
for sure.
No one's criticizing who you are.
We just sometimes you need to see from
someone else's perspective because you
don't even realize like you might have
these little roadblocks he keep bumping
into and you're like,
hey man,
I used to go around that bitch.
You don't even realize like people
don't.
You run into like one or two people that
want you to fail.
Guess what?
Those people don't even really want you
to fail.
They just don't feel good.
Right?
They're mad at you.
They look at anybody who doesn't want
someone to do well.
If I see someone that's a total fuck up,
I want them to do better.
It doesn't have to just be better for
me.
Positive way.
If they're better,
it affects me in a negative way if they
fail,
but that.
So you're running into people.
It's a bad sample like you're running
into people like so often when you're
paying attention to social media,
you're running into people that are
judging you because of their own
feelings,
right?
Yeah,
that's true.
And that affects you.
It affects the way you think and the way
you think about the word.
Try not to engage every engaged.
Really the negativity.
It's you can't,
it's not good.
You encourage it.
And there's people that feed off of it
and on both sides,
you know,
like there's like Owen Benjamin,
I gotta text them just fucking fighting
with people online.
You know,
he's been on.
He's a fucking smart dude too.
Yeah,
he's smart,
but he's caught up in that,
that weirdness of like get out of there
and just kept walking and he does a lot
of that too.
He does build fires and sit out.
He does that too.
Did you guys see Jamie Kilstein?
Oh,
it's totally.
I saw them and feed them here.
I had him here for two and a half hours.
You really think I did not listen to
that whole weight.
Was that that was a response to the one
or are you saying this is a separate
thing?
Separate one recently?
No,
but I'm saying what you know,
his whole thing was that he was this guy
who was attacking people online.
Jamie was.
Jamie was like a full on social justice
warrior,
Vegan,
Vegan warrior.
He's not anymore.
No.
Oh,
you don't know what happened.
I have no idea.
Oh,
it's a crazy story.
Who's been molesting children separated
from his girlfriend or his wife rather
than some sort of a open situation.
And during that open situation he had
had sex with a couple of the girls and
they decided that he wasn't some way
predatory.
Who's right and who's wrong.
I'm not going to engage in because I do
not know.
I would hope that,
uh,
it's a bunch of misunderstandings.
I hope that he didn't do anything wrong
and they didn't lie about him doing
something wrong,
but he didn't.
I don't know.
I don't know really what happened,
but what he talked about that was honest
was about how he would feel going after
people trying to get people fired.
He would feel good.
Yeah,
you feel good,
you feel fired up,
but he would also feel engaged and,
and,
and part of it was like,
you're terrified of other people coming
after you,
so you're going to go after the show
your virtue and attack and that,
you know,
he was just so caught up in it that he
wasn't even like looking at stories
objective,
Lee.
He was like,
it's like finding a direction that he
should definitely go into to get the
most reaction from all these people that
are supporting this direction.
MMM.
Comics who already goes after who?
Just posts statements where they're
trying to get likes.
Yeah.
Well there's a lot of that for sure.
Signaling,
but they're like,
wow,
look what I believe.
Like you're right,
you're right.
But ignore them.
Like they just let,
let the fucking regular folks.
Sometimes it's tied to them like they're
not that good of friends.
Yeah.
Louis Gunn was always fucking posts,
posts,
pictures of his goddamn new girlfriend,
and it's like Lewis,
come on.
Well,
he's in love.
Better than that.
Why don't you see?
What happens is the grant has done that.
Every single guy has done that were
like,
come on,
don't be ridiculous,
and then when they fall in love,
but I really love her.
I want everyone to know when she finds a
new man,
that's my favorite part.
Posting all those dudes that's sticking
in your face over and over again.
How deeply they are in love.
When you know their pigs,
you're like,
this can't last your savaged.
By the way,
all those go.
Those guys.
We were hiking,
we were taking pictures of their
girlfriends.
They're like,
not taking it like this.
Now I'll take it again like this.
Those pictures are going to be used on
their tinder account.
When they break up,
right to get laid.
You took a picture of me to get me laid
thing,
man,
you got to welcome them.
You gotta give him the golf clap when
they get some new deck.
Y'all take care.
I love you.
I want you to have that expression.
You take care.
Bye.
Yeah,
you gotta.
Be careful.
You got to be careful who you fucking
link link hooks with.
Jamie's.
That podcast you did with Jamie was
really good and I say this as someone
who liked Jamie originally and then when
he did the podcast with you and red
band,
I guessed,
but like where you call it,
you guys rapists.
You never.
No,
no,
no.
He didn't call us rapist.
Don't definitely charge you with rape.
He called it.
He joked around about red band being a
rapist afterwards because red band
criticized him after being on the show.
It was like it was really stupid,
but I never disliked him after that,
but I was like.
I was like,
man,
that was fucked up because he did
represent that story incorrectly.
Well,
this is what you're talking about is
video called the kills team
where this guy,
Brendon Brandon,
took one part of what we said together
and then kills Dean's version of it.
Spliced them together so you could see
what we actually said when he read,
when he recorded it on his show.
To all the super lefties,
but he was super honest about it when he
came on the podcast.
New podcast man.
And I'm glad we're.
He's still.
He does stand up right,
because he still wants to do it again.
Wasn't stopped.
He wants to stop.
He stopped,
dude.
They went after him.
They attacked him like,
and here's the thing.
Whether or not he was guilty of basic
normal,
slimy male type behavior that we do on
occasionally,
especially when intoxicated,
try to get late.
Whether he was guilty of that.
The way I'm wrong.
By the way,
if you are guilty of that.
Okay.
I know you.
I've been here and uh,
you know,
and I don't trust people don't have that
on their roster.
Right?
Trying to get late.
Not Too much.
Just like also being young.
Cool.
Being drunk,
taking a chance.
Just like you tell a few jokes onstage,
don't work.
Sure.
Right.
We were talking on the boat.
Me,
Ren,
another guy,
another guy.
Could you write it down for me?
It's rich Vos were like,
oh,
I can leave Harvey Weinstein jacked off
in front of a chick.
I can't believe I can't believe it.
And then I go,
well,
I did it once and it's like,
wait,
hold on,
you can't do it at all?
And he's like,
yeah,
it's definitely happened.
Like if you're mutually masturbated with
a chick.
Oh.
And I did it with a girl boss did it
with a girl,
get me legitimately nervous.
I was about 25 years old.
She said that she will masturbate in
front of each of them all.
I got,
dude,
she's too aggressive.
So me and this girl,
she used to bartender at the Boston
comedy club coke.
We ended up going back to my place.
Listen to Ani Difranco light a candle,
a lesbian baby.
She has a boyfriend.
She has a boyfriend and she's like,
listen,
I can't,
I can't fuck.
You can both get naked and just
masturbate across the room from each
other.
Oh,
what a good thing for her boyfriend and
the boyfriend's.
Can you elaborate to the limit toys?
Normal.
So I said spit in your hand course.
I spent my.
Hold on a second.
Hold on one second.
What if you asked her to spit on your
guys might be cheating?
I don't know.
I jerked off with her spirit is.
Didn't ask her.
We were across the room from each other.
Why?
Why is it hot or knowing that she has a
boyfriend.
I,
Chris Ryan can help it.
It.
And then when did you know
what rich was her boyfriend?
No,
no,
no.
So the toenails a slightly chipped
smokes.
When drunk.
She had smelly feet,
the kind of waitress feet,
you know,
smell the waitress waitress feet.
We get very,
very specific.
That's how we talk at waffle house or
sometimes when you're married so long
you fantasize about just going back to
the girl with smelly feet and smoking a
bowl with those little bum pack and
bowls and bowls.
So that's it.
And so you got me saying earlier with
heartfelt.
So we both come and then she says,
she says,
listen,
I'm heading back to Brooklyn Hollow.
Tell anyone about this.
Definitely don't talk about it on a
podcast.
He goes,
I didn't say her name yet.
And so,
uh,
she goes,
you definitely can't tell the rich boss.
And I go,
okay.
She goes,
I mean,
seriously,
don't tell rich balls.
I go,
that's an odd.
So I used to work the door at the club,
so I walked to the club at like seven
because that's when I had to sit out and
bosses back when he smoked,
it was sitting out smoking a cigarette.
I was like,
what's up boxing?
He's like,
I heard you jacked off in front of Jenny
last night.
He goes,
me too.
I had to give a ride to Brooklyn.
You said a name,
you asshole.
Her name was Jenny.
Good.
Gets up on your stinky.
Wait.
Don't sometimes get into,
you know,
that's a thing that there's connections
that happen,
especially when you're young.
But Chris Ryan did talk about.
But when you have sex with someone,
when you're real young,
if something happens,
like there's a trigger that goes off and
that thing can become like a fetish for
sure.
It's like weird stockings or stinky
waitress feet or rubber gloves.
Rubber.
The rubber,
the rubber gloves.
Rubber gloves thing.
You get jerked off by a maid?
Nope.
I don't know where they came from.
Yellow rubber gloves.
Did you ever go to get where it came
from like you came from,
but that's what you're talking about a
different thing.
Then the idea is you get where it came
from.
It's like like a girl,
like you used to bang this chick.
She worked together with you.
You guys were both tired.
He got off work.
You're all sweaty.
She takes her shoes off her feet.
Stank.
Who Cares?
You eat her pussy like you don't give a
fuck.
Tastes a little pissy,
but whatever.
Who gives a shit both beers in.
Especially like if you come when
anything like you know,
out of the norm is happening that enough
times that's going to be tied in those
settings.
Right?
When you having an orgasm,
you hear cops were dudes get like foot
fetishes.
I got foot finishes.
Eighth Grade.
Jennifer Stevens used to play with her
flip flop and dangle it and just dangle
it right when I'm finding my sexuality
like eighth grade he flagged it on.
It's going to be problematic
and dude,
I've been into feet ever fucking prepare
for an onslaught of photographs.
Offended your inbox,
sir.
Hop songs that are hot seat.
Yeah.
Well it's definitely not going to
happen.
You're going to get punched or not hot.
You're going to get a bunch of guys.
By the way.
Bert likes guy feet.
So big fucking obsession with cameron
hanes.
His feet right now.
After he did that and he was posting
pictures of his feet.
He jerked off.
No,
but I'm losing a toenail to.
And I was like more pictures of your
feet like I didn't tell.
But boy,
come on guys.
We're getting drunk.
Come on.
Yeah,
they lose their toenails all the time.
That's not courtney.
Courtney.
And lose shit and lose.
Wow.
The blisters blistered.
She's my new bedsheets.
Fifty eight hours at somewhere else and
68 hours.
Yep.
Wow.
That's not only that.
She won by almost a marathon.
Thirteen percent.
She won by almost two.
I think it was more than 22 miles to
one,
but that's wild.
So like when she crossed she could have
taken,
this is what I was going to do,
a marathon after she finished to catch
up.
This is what I described to her on the
podcast.
I go,
you could have taken an eight hour
sleep,
a real good solid sleep room service.
Took a nice warm shower,
felt good eight a fat steak and fries,
a coke,
and then you could have gone there and
watch that poor fuck the second place,
Dude.
That's why the way she.
It's very rare than women when those
things.
Although there was two huge winds by
women in a row,
a woman run one that she wanted the mob
to 40,
which is one of the most insane
endurance races ever.
And then a woman won the New York City
marathon on Saturday or on Sunday for
the first time in 40 years.
Yeah,
but she.
But she was not just the first American.
She was like the first woman with him at
the same time.
What the guys,
the guy won like 20 minutes faster than
her.
She was the first American to win that
race and ms dot soul back in horribles
headlines and stories like weird.
A few times she was the winner and they
like American.
One was the first female to win the
marathon in four American woman to mid.
No marathon visit dude Nigerian again.
That's horrible.
Set Nigerian guy.
He's just the only way.
The only way she can get faster sucks.
Dick,
the woman who won,
the only way she can get faster.
She's got to get on that.
Oh,
you're right.
Yeah,
it's probably some dude from that.
Women wins.
New York City Marathon for the first
time in 40 years.
That way I give so little fucks about
marathon running.
That's as far into it as I look,
but they lied.
So it's that an American woman winning
the women's side.
You know the people who do the headlines
for these things are not the people who
write the articles,
of course.
And you matter how much you ask them
that like,
no,
we're running the headline.
That's implying with,
oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That happens.
Do you imagine if you fucking running
that thing next year,
you'll crush everybody.
You will crush most people.
You could do it easy.
Easy.
How about this?
You will be first of all,
whites.
How about we give props to his dad?
Show survivor,
a Holocaust survivor.
Yes.
Fucking years old.
He didn't know that.
Tom Towe story,
marathon,
Romania runs six hours,
six hours,
26 minutes.
I can't do that.
That's almost 80.
I tend to.
Yeah,
I saw you guys baiting me and my dad.
I couldn't beat your dad.
Your Dad's your dad's 80.
I would when I would have not went out
to finish in like eight hours.
Your dad first marathon,
a 15 hour and a half ahead of time.
60th five.
The Irish.
My name is spelled backwards.
What's your name?
What's his name?
Says now how you found your privacy,
but is an 80 year old guy recovering
from a fucking marathon.
Give them that.
Why the Holocaust still still in there?
Did he get called when?
When,
uh,
when they wrote that movie about the
Korean leader Seth Rogen and stuff,
head writer's name should appear so we
get mistaken for each other the whole
time.
The like,
Oh,
you were in the rose.
Congratulations.
But wasn't made.
It was crazy.
We met once,
but I got calls at my parents' house
from the fucking Mossad saying we need
a,
uh,
an interview with you.
And they were like,
I hear the liquor anymore.
He's like,
he's going to do that interview.
Whoa.
Wait,
what?
I'm like,
it wasn't me.
Really thought it was.
You didn't do it because it's us going
to talk to us about it.
Holy Shit.
I'm like,
Nah,
man.
She pleaded to join the Marine Corp
Marathon Sunday.
She came in first against chicks are
dudes.
This is the whole thing.
Winds,
women's division of the marine corner so
that Nana dammit.
My bed time of 2:45.
You couldn't be that way.
I couldn't beat that and a half the same
thing.
So listen,
I hate to be the guy,
but like are we admitting that it's
impossible for women to compete in a
marathon and gets men?
Because Courtney do alter can when she
shows you she can she can she one giant
margin.
So where,
where would this lady have come in?
Like if in the all over division how
many men?
Peter's my question is this man was to
25.
What should come into 45?
What'd you come it overall?
Like how many people were around them at
the same time?
A,
if she's still came in seventh,
then you're like,
yeah,
those seven people hadn't signed that.
She would have won that as possible,
but this is the thing about debt,
courtney check.
It makes you wonder like,
what if there's like a number where you
pass where it's just in your mind,
like you can get to a place where it's
your body,
like you can get to a place where you
train hard.
It's fairly easy,
but there's a number that you passed,
whether it's 100 miles or 200 miles or
whatever that number is where it's just
your mind.
It doesn't matter how strong you are
because you can force your body to do
things that it doesn't want to do.
Whether they can do.
Who else did
have.
What's his name?
He's actually transitioning.
Eddie izzard.
He's transitioning.
Transitioning.
Yeah.
He's.
He's running for political office as a.
As a woman right now.
Yeah,
but you know,
he did his whole act as a woman that
came to be in,
but none of them,
but no announced that now full of
physician.
Do you know about the running smooth?
I do know about the fucking running and
read that headline.
Twenty seven marathons in seven days.
He started it out with zero running.
Oh well that burt can do it.
You Man.
This is a dude that's.
There's some.
There's a fire in his fucking mom.
My Dad,
my dad.
When my dad heard about this.
You can run a marathon.
No fucking problem.
Really?
Yeah.
Because look,
there are people that do it for the
first time all the fucking time now
time.
I.
I know.
I don't think so.
The reason I say that is like he sees
it.
I'll know on November 19th I would like
to try to run a sub two hour half
marathon.
I'm going to win the whole thing.
If you don't go into what you're not
going to win.
You need to have the attitude of your
gutter west.
Okay.
Let's put away from it.
What do we have to dangle?
Dangle something and you'll watch me
hurt myself.
Yeah.
That Harley.
What Harley Harley did that you didn't
want it?
Robert,
what's the color?
I want it to go at a time down time,
but when the edit this out.
No,
no,
no.
What are you running this marathon?
I'm running two weeks doing this
marathon.
Two weeks.
How?
How much is the.
Is the.
Is the barber?
I don't know.
If you don't know.
What are we talking?
I don't know how he keeps ringing.
Trying to figure out what's going on and
see.
How much is that?
Barbara is about $15,000.
Sounds good to me.
Sounds really what it is.
Harley Davidson.
The nice and tricked out.
I'm sure there's a list or you're
running a marathon in two weeks.
Doing a half marathon in November 19th.
Look at that bill.
What's Nice about this one which you
really want is like one of them fucking
cruising bikes,
right?
Damage.
Hardly.
That's not a bad bike.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's what I'm talking about.
Whole screen.
That's a beautiful bike.
Look at that.
Don't you wish those weren't dangerous?
Dangerous at five and they're not
dangerous.
They fix your blood pressure,
but don't you wish you could just ride a
motorcycle?
You have never been more in your moment.
What's a good.
What's a good time to hit on a half
marathon,
half marathon.
You're doing the whole sober and I was
signed up for flying classes and tm.
I signed up for everything and my wife's
like,
no,
it's taken flying class till no.
Okay,
but flying class,
like a cheerleader
or flying class shouldn't do that.
Go to a chair too.
Little ones.
Flatters.
You would be the best fucking
cheerleader.
If you have champions on the team.
Looks like the mountain for the game of
thrones thinking.
You can turn.
Oh my God.
At Florida state season in Redmond,
cheerleader.
This is what we get.
Icelandic dudes and you in a fucking
speedo with your flip flops on.
You're flipping through the air and
catching you like you're a pillow.
Oh,
you got a bottle of Tito's in your hand
while you're flipping.
Just drawing these guys.
Are they just there are animals,
those dudes,
those d one cheerleaders or we're not
going to use those pussies.
We're going to use all those dudes.
Do that strong man thing where they grab
a beer keg.
Motherfuckers.
Yeah.
That's right,
that's the guy you want chuck you in the
air.
Wait,
what's a good time for a marathon
though?
But what's a full.
What's.
What's a good time for five hours was
the one we all talked about that
originally was really hard to do,
right?
You're totally right,
How many men beat five hours in the last
marathon?
What's the abject marathon in?
New York's different because you have to
qualify for it,
so that's something like the average
people beat five hours knowing that you
have to qualify.
Let's take a look at a lot or marine
corps.
What's your goal?
My goal in my head is always been doing
the half.
What's your goal in the half?
Two hours and 30 minutes for five hours
for a full weight.
It's not really a slow down.
Slow down.
He's a runner.
To average finish at the New York
marathon was four hours.
Thirty four minutes.
Five.
Six,
seven minute miles.
Yeah.
This guy's finished it two hours.
Franklin Franklin,
I had a bit way back in the 19 eighties,
was hilarious about the Olympics.
He goes,
hey.
I don't look at the guy who wins.
He goes,
I look at the guy who loses.
he goes,
you look at his face when he's coming.
He's like,
God damn,
I'm going to come in last and the
Olympics,
and he starts thinking,
man,
if I didn't even fucking train,
that's still coming.
Last things all the time,
train.
He goes,
never reality started setting in and you
see how he's like,
I don't even have a fucking job.
So true.
It's a great bit,
man.
Fucking great bit.
And start that off with going like,
because he in his country,
this is the fastest.
So he started going down,
going to win the Olympic gold and he'd
like,
you run your first few paces down and
then you come up and then it was like,
what the fuck is your firm?
Try to crack two hours.
I think that would be impossible for me.
Jamie,
what's that?
Six minutes.
Six miles an hour.
That's a 10 minute
mile miles really fast.
What's your normal mouse?
If you would just want to find five
miles.
If I was going to go out and run five
miles treadmill,
a treadmill,
what's.
I got one of those arrows.
Salts.
They're sick.
Yeah.
I got to thank the guy I wish I could
think.
And he stumped.
And uh,
I don't know what the name of the
company is.
What's the name of the company?
Aerosault.
And he was so cool.
He said,
man,
I heard you talk about it.
I want to just hook you up.
He's like,
I don't need anything.
They don't need anything.
Just enjoy it.
And it was so cool.
Difference.
There's um,
there's treadmills that come towards
you.
Treadmills that are basically like a sea
let us run on one.
It's called Ron at one that says,
has wood in the name because it's all
wood part aerosol.
One that they gave her some serious.
Yeah.
It's way better for you than running on
a treadmill because like Bert was
telling,
talking about is running times.
Then I was thinking,
you have things coming towards you.
It doesn't matter.
I'm like,
I think it does matter.
So you got one of those.
Burt A.
Yeah.
This is the thing,
so this runner,
it's called the air runner.
Yeah,
that's it.
The air runner,
not aerosol,
but there is an air assault bike.
That's what you're thinking of.
That's a rogue.
This is a good way.
It makes a treadmill when I was thinking
of.
Because this thing is that like a slight
angle.
You're also running on the toes of your
feet and the ball of your feet to
instead of flat on the ground.
So how many,
how many minutes to go on that?
Miles an hour.
I only,
right now I'm just getting that set up
in the man cave.
I haven't gotten on it.
It's A.
I could do 10 minute miles very easily
for on a treadmill on the road.
I'm.
I'm at like 11 minute miles times.
How many?
Thirteen miles.
Okay.
That's beneath two hours.
It was just carrying extra weight.
You're carrying extra weight if you just
committed to some so you could actually
live the lifestyle you live in because
you're not gaining any weight can be
shredded.
Yeah.
He might know.
You have to think about this when it
comes to like body,
like what you're carrying around with
your body,
like you're not gaining a lot of weight.
You're pretty consistent,
right?
When you taste the weight,
like Tommy,
you've been very consistent,
very consistent with his shirt off.
He's a beautiful man.
Oh,
it's true.
It's true.
It's not true,
but what happened?
What did you think you gained weight,
size of private.
He said you won't get wet and you won't
step on a scale in front of him.
He said,
you never asked me after the podcast.
He was like,
let's all go away.
And you said I don't have time.
I kissed her and then I got and were
point four pounds lighter than me.
Right.
But I haven't gained weight.
No,
no,
no.
But the way Joe says it is you've been
very good at it.
You don't to do that to fuck with you
or.
No,
and you know what though?
I ended up feeling like Lindsay Lohan
and or apartment where I go,
hold on.
Tamara Lohan and her apartment.
Tell me more.
Are you delivering the coke?
He just,
they went into,
rob's,
our teacher called you fat.
Hey teacher,
call you fat,
no called you by your name,
fat.
She goes,
is fat here,
blah,
blah.
What teachers is the nicest one?
She goes,
your friend fat.
And I said,
what?
And she goes,
I'm sorry,
and she goes like that.
And I go,
burt.
She goes,
burt mindset,
he's,
he's on the road to understand this by
yourself and you will only point four
pounds below him,
right?
And you are over an inch shorter than
him is so much fatter than you get it.
It's uncomfortable.
You should be with the extra inch.
Same Height.
You should be thinner,
but you're this round.
I don't initially want to go.
Tom and I are going to leave you guys.
You guys figure this out.
I gotTa pee.
I gotta remember where the bathroom.
I want to see both your bellies.
It doesn't make sense.
Can we be honest?
We're going to talk about this when we
get back.
So p and think about this.
Fat Shaming.
Want to talk about fat shaming when you
come back?
Oh,
when we were kids,
there was no such thing and I think the
world was dispatched.
Yes,
the world was a better place.
There just happened to me.
I don't think you should be happy being
fat.
I don't think anybody should be mean to
you because you're fat,
but I think there's a.
You could do.
You'd feel better if you weren't.
That's it if you weren't fat.
Yeah,
yeah.
Maybe it should be.
Something else was like shaming fat,
shaming,
so it's like I've seen him talk about
fighters,
like,
oh,
one fighter tried to bully the other
fighter.
I'm like,
what are you talking about?
They're about to kick the shit out of
each.
Try to impose his game.
This is psychological warfare.
Can you call him a bully?
You can't really call him bully because
he's a champ.
That's how you say the champ.
Keep everybody scared.
Remember Mike Tyson,
the eighties to the greatest time to be
alive for a box.
He was bullied when he got 100 percent.
Oh my God.
That words bullshit.
The word should apply to someone who's
picking on someone who's meek,
but to push out a more little kid.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
There's something about that that's like
horrible,
but you can't apply that to things that
aren't real bullies.
Especially like fighters talking shit to
each other.
They're not being bullies.
They're engaging in your.
You're trying to get a psychological
upper hand.
We all know that.
That's real to pretend to psychological
upper hands,
like forget about fighting.
What about girls?
You remember when there was a girl that
you did not think you could talk to and
if she talked to you,
you'd fucking lock up and panic in
there.
That's like there's a psychological
position when you feel like you're not
in the position to be able to like kiss
that girl or have sex with that girl.
It was like,
there's no way.
Especially when you're a teenager,
you're like baffled because yeah,
you don't even know.
You don't know which one's going to like
you.
Which one's not like,
why do people like you?
Why do they not like you remember the
feeling?
I remember that girl that had boobs was
like,
one day I'll have boobs,
ips,
like one day you do have boobs,
boobs.
Here you go.
Hey,
it's,
it is.
Um.
Yeah,
but you're back to play a prank or
something back that is new for black
girls in high school where you couldn't
believe that they liked you.
Like meeting people.
Like when you were young,
like when you would,
if you,
a girl would like,
you are not like,
you either have no idea.
It's almost like you like a,
like you opened up a page in Spanish and
someone told you what the word is.
Like,
oh,
okay.
That's what it means.
All right,
good.
Yeah.
That's a little unit before.
I really have no idea why I would like,
you are not like you,
like when when you're a teenager,
when you're in high school,
you know when it goes sideways,
Midwest.
And I was like,
oh,
I'll never get that again.
Never again.
And it's over.
And then you smell like desperation or
do you remember when like someone
because you're genuinely not interested.
Oh yeah.
Then when you discover that your lack of
interest gets interest and you're like,
why?
Like you're not saying that that's it.
Yeah.
And you're like,
fuck,
now you like me?
And like,
yeah,
but like,
I,
I really don't like you.
They're like,
I like even more.
That's how you operate.
Date me,
it's very,
it's weirdly weird.
Psychology.
You're like,
but I don't like it.
But girl turned around doggystyle
spreading her butt cheeks apart.
Looking back at you and it's gonna be a
cartoon.
Balloon says,
validate me,
Tommy buns.
Now there is for sure.
Yeah.
That's the worst.
That was.
So that's always so weird.
That holds.
And then you're like,
but I do like you.
And she's like,
and I hate the attention that the
obviousness,
you know?
That's what,
when people say mean shit about you when
you're not around anymore,
like that fucking loser.
Anyway.
Oh really?
Is that what it is?
He's a loser loser because he doesn't
want to fuck anymore.
Now it's terrible.
Terrible.
His head.
What was it gave me the whole time you
were dating for three years.
Warning signs.
Then feeling of pain that we have when
someone leaves us.
I mean,
have you ever,
uh,
never mind you thought about that one.
One more drink.
Two or three more drinks.
He's got a strong sense of.
He's got a good appetite.
Did you guys get super high when you
start smoking again?
Oh God.
Terrifyingly high.
I was terrified before.
Went up at a master's regard.
No.
So high.
I was,
I forget what I was talking about.
You did that high.
Fuck.
Fuck man.
I wouldn't do.
I could've kept going.
We kept going either two hours earlier
trying to hotbox Enn Edwards.
He was totally sober.
That's a weird thing about traveling
with.
And he's got damn hilarious,
but he's a Vegan and he's fully sober.
He's so fun.
He doesn't drink.
He doesn't smoke.
He doesn't do anything.
Does he?
Um.
Do you guys go out to eat then?
He's still this weird conversation where
the waves are like,
there's no cheese.
There's no cheese on that.
Do you use butter?
Like you can't use butter.
It's so whack.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
I couldn't go vegan thing.
He goes,
I stopped drinking.
I think we just opened up the door to
the next challenge.
Can we dip our toes in with vegetarian?
Maybe if you're going to go vegetarian,
you can have eggs,
but you can't have milk or cheese
because I'll give you the eggs.
How about that?
We got a yellow corvette with your name
on it.
You have to get the order.
I'll do that in New York.
No,
no,
no.
Everyone's going to be getting in your
car like your taxi.
Fully Tarian,
but with eggs that I give you guys
because I have.
I have eggs.
I have too many eggs.
I gave away eggs.
All my chickens are fucking bolting and
they're not laying eggs.
Really got bitch ass.
Chickens definitely have chickens.
You might have pitched chickens to feed
them.
Good food too.
Yeah,
we do too,
but all chickens.
Mom,
my chickens do two.
I have once a month.
20 chickens to get eggs once a month.
I'm like,
I'm going to get eggs today.
He's a good dude.
Yeah,
I know.
But you know what's good about written
and if you have your own chickens,
their Karma free.
Those say those chickens don't give a
fuck about those eggs.
Those eggs will never be a chicken.
And you have a good relationship with
the chickens.
I feed them food.
They give me eggs.
It's simple.
It's like it's not,
it's not like an imbalance because the
would it cost to feed the chickens is
basically what it cost to buy eggs.
Do you ever,
uh,
ever feed him watermelon runs,
feed everything.
Stay on mice,
mice,
mice in there?
Yeah.
They go crazy.
Breakup one leg.
I told her a story.
So in the interest of brevity,
I'll tell it.
I'll tell it quickly.
This is what happened.
Yes.
Oh my God.
If you peed on myself,
go crazy.
Or there yolks become a dark,
dark orange too.
It's hard.
Um,
we,
uh,
we put in a glass fence in the back of
my yard and hawks keeps slamming into
the glass fence.
We've killed at least three and Koh
several more.
Or were these hawks or Kale blood coming
out of the nose.
Yeah,
dude,
I've seen him a camera.
That's probably a good idea.
But it only happens like once a month.
But anyway.
One,
one hawk got code came back,
but at a fucked up wing.
So,
uh,
we take the Hawk and we preserve it and
we put the hawk in like this container
and we get some food for it from the pet
store.
The pet store,
these things called pinkies,
it would have pinky is,
is a little tiny baby mouse that's
already.
It's weaning off its mother's blind and
they feed them is snakes.
It's horrible.
Horrible Shit.
So we get pinkies for this hok as Hok
fucks up these pinkies all except one
pinky.
We get the hock to the wildlife place
where they repair wildlife on Monday,
you know,
it's like one of those,
uh,
places where they deal with injured and
drive a hawk there.
Yeah,
we took the hockey puck and they're
worried about getting out to slow.
The hawks are,
you know,
they're,
they're very valuable thinking about
back to the ecosystem and put it in the
trunk.
But they're important.
No,
you put them in front of you is how
evolution works.
You've got to do your part whenever
possible,
but these hawks got to figure out.
That's a fucking fancy dumb cunt.
I could see the fence.
How can we don't see the fence?
I guess you don't deserve to evolve.
That's so fucking core.
So we're left with one pinky on full
full 60 miles an hour.
Like a feather.
Here's what's fucked up.
I've seen it happen a couple of times.
She paint mice on the,
on the glass box.
Come in full.
I have a photo with a rabbit with a
steel spike who write with a rabbit.
Like flying right into your rabbit.
Yeah.
So when it was done was one pinky
leftovers.
The Hawk did neat and my daughters
wanted to keep the pinky as a pen.
I'm like,
it's going to die.
It can't eat.
It's going to.
It's supposed to be weaning off its
mother.
It probably shouldn't even be alive
still.
It's a day later I go,
let's just feed it to the chicken and
everybody freaked the fuck out.
Like you're a monster.
You're an asshole.
I go,
okay,
listen.
No,
it's good.
No one called him an asshole.
They're nine and seven.
That's crazy.
I say this like you can take his pinky
and I could bring it back to the pet
store,
but they're just going to feed it to a
snake.
I go,
that's what they have in there for.
They have to feed them to.
The mother won't accept it.
It has our smell on it.
I go,
it's going to die.
let's just feed it to the chickens.
I go,
why is it okay to feed it to the hawks
but it's not okay to feed to the
chickens.
So they're like,
do you think the chickens are going to
eat it?
I go,
I fucking know they have.
They're going to eat it because I have
youtube.
I've watched on till you see it happen.
I saw them chase it,
a mouse once that got in there and fuck
it up,
so I knew they were going to do it and I
put that mouse on the ground.
Do they dart on that thing in less than
one second?
One chicken had it and it was running
around and all the other chickens were
chasing her and they were running around
trying to kill it.
They tore it apart.
Now if I put a plate of corn down,
they barely flinched.
Go.
Okay.
Time to eat.
Peck.
Peck,
The district.
How often do you give them?
Mice?
Very rarely.
It's only happened one time.
Oh,
oh,
shut up.
That's what happens.
That never happens with any other food.
I know there's plenty of stuff in there
for all of us know,
but that one chicken has that mouse and
she'll have to fight for it.
All the other ones who gang up on her
cornered?
Cornered.
Sorry.
Hen It's like she's got to get them as
quick as you can,
but like rewards,
selfishness.
This chicken is running away.
I'm getting some pains in my yard.
That's a
pink mouse,
but you could do that with full on mice,
man.
Your.
Your chickens are designed to kill mice.
Wallachia.
We have this idea of what they are.
Oh,
you do?
Definitely.
It's definitely not one piston
neighbors.
Get a rooster rooster.
Spanish neighborhood though.
They appreciate you.
Yeah.
We had to call one time for that when we
lived in that Spanish neighborhood.
Did you really?
It was waking everybody up fucking every
morning and this guy just had it like on
a chain and the concrete back yard.
I'm good.
I'm cool.
Why is this a weed that makes you
uncomfortable?
But the booze doesn't know.
I've got at the very beginning of this
podcast and I noticed that I was being
quiet,
which might be a very good thing.
You'd been fine.
Everything seems normal.
Give us another recap of game of
thrones.
Wished he'd never shot that redhead.
Check with an Arrow because I do.
Oh yeah.
I feel like they could have worked at
shit out.
My wife watched John Snow.
Fuck a fucked out.
Not Wolverine.
What was the same shit?
She went down on her and Leanne's like
pretty clean and he was like during that
cave and Leanne just goes,
how bad do you think wildling pussy
smell?
Think about shit like that.
I went to that.
I saw that hot tub where they went and
did it.
The underground hot hot spring for real.
Wow.
Where was in Ireland?
Northern Iceland.
Iceland.
Wow.
Look at you in Iceland.
Isn't ever going to be a show like that
if there's never going to be a movie
that rather than has the impact of a
show like that episodes.
I've never seen it.
Never seen game of thrones,
never seen him have no interest,
no interest.
You know,
like dragons don't like dragons.
What do you like any show that you do?
Like I just finished a mine hunter last
night.
Great.
I heard it's great.
It's great for hunter on Netflix.
So it's about how the FBI established
the,
uh,
criminal profiling a system.
In other words,
they used to not have behavioral science
department.
They said these guys go around the
interview serial killers and to try to
get research.
Yeah,
it's,
it's fucking cool.
You're a fan of that.
And also big bang theory.
That was my favorite comedy.
That's my favorite kind of WHO's,
who's not in agreement,
but come on guys,
I didn't hear that.
The show.
Big Bang theory.
You ever seen this video on youtube of
the Big Bang theory with no laugh track?
No.
Horrible.
We don't want to play it because I want
him to be getting mad at us.
You ever watch a Sitcom on TV?
At a bar?
I just see it on mute and just be like,
oh look how obvious.
They're big.
So it's terrifying.
It's to watch somebody watch one of
those shows and laugh.
Have you ever been the room?
Like in other words like a show like
that is on.
No,
like,
like a show,
like some sitcoms on TV and you're with
somebody and it's just like the kind of
thing you'd walk by and be like,
whatever.
And then they're like,
and they start really laughing at those
set up,
like really mature.
No,
you are.
No you are.
Yeah.
And then you see them laughing.
You're like,
holy,
this is a whole other level that your
existing on.
Yeah.
But it also like,
that's really good really making you
laugh,
you know,
it shows you like how subjective it
really is because there's a lot of
people.
There's like 20 million people a week
that watched that shit man.
A lot the most.
Watch that crazy.
Yeah.
When you watch one of those and you and
you and you see somebody really,
really laughing at that and you're like,
wow,
you can just point in that direction to
get most actors in those shows like
there's at least there's not more people
who killed themselves for being on big.
All I got for seven,
eight years.
I could totally do it.
You can kill yourself after being on
that long.
No,
I can just do one of those shows really.
Of course,
I just like,
Nah,
because I'm phoning it in.
It would have to be my show.
It can be totally shitty.
Yeah.
We would have to be my show about me and
it can be totally shitty.
I'd never leave it.
Oh,
well,
I'm Myrna Myrna and bird bird.
Merger time traveling daughters and they
do it ventures daily.
You would totally be into it.
Yeah.
Yeah,
percent.
Of course.
All the time for seven years,
no matter how awful it got it,
as long as I was like enjoying the cast
and were all partying and paid and get
paid.
I'm riding a chopper to work at CBS
Radford,
stopping by perennial marijuana and
getting a one hitter because we don't
drug test on her show.
When's the next?
When's the next marathon in Los Angeles
that you could do full marathon,
full marathon that you could actually
get to Jane.
We got to set up a.
We got to set up those treats at the end
of the fucking.
You know the,
the finish line.
You have one of those,
but yeah,
I have one of those bobbers parked there
and have it.
Burt,
congratulations.
But then like the second somebody goes
wrong.
What do you think is a real no bullshit
achievable time for you at full
marathon?
Full Marathon.
Jim,
you gotta help me.
You run your 45,
a little over two.
It'd be a pretty good full marathons,
full five fives as it got five has to be
a good mark because after that three
hour mark or even doing the half,
you're going to hit a real tough wall,
but you also will be running with the
pace group the whole time,
which helps and I'll be running around
like I have to go with them no matter
what.
I have to go with them five hours,
five hours.
That's hilarious.
I don't even know what I'm saying.
I'm thinking about draining my bank
account to bet you.
Hold on Joe.
Five hours.
What do we do in here?
I like this.
Do you think he could do it five hours?
Hey,
hold on.
I'm thinking Ra and I could make some
serious money.
Let's get up.
Let's get it.
Let's get a course that we're talking
because we're not going to do one in
Colorado.
I don't want to.
I want to.
Boston,
it will keep you alive.
Say like five hours.
You would have to really prepare that
time.
He's willing.
I want to see what he's in shape right
now,
so wait.
He had to really prepare to do five
hours.
I think you could do it.
I'm not saying you couldn't do it.
If we're not giving you a year,
idiot.
Fuck.
You're going to do it once.
The next marathon.
What's what?
What city?
They're going to be in San Diego,
La and we're not saying you could be in
shape at a later date.
For now,
right now.
Right now I've never heard any.
And Fuck was more humor.
Vitriol,
hatred.
Perfect.
It was perfect.
Idiot.
Fuck you idiot.
Bakersfield Marathon.
Let's do a marathon where we can get
depressed.
North face and North San Francisco wits.
But what about Bakersfield?
What happened?
Come out feeling stuff.
Seems like a page.
Long Beach.
Santa Barbara.
Seven seventh.
Fake it really quick.
Turnarounds guys.
It's just in a couple of days,
isn't it?
Hold on,
hold on,
hold on.
Let's do you go to Tampa?
Fifty miles.
He can't run.
He's not going to run 50 miles,
Bro.
No.
That too.
So there's about 13 point one.
There's a 26 point two trail run trail
run.
Oh,
you'll die because you do a marathon and
a trail.
That'd be easier for,
you know,
trevor will be harder.
Let's do that.
Do that.
No,
no,
no.
Rock the coast.
Coast Long Beach.
December second.
It's plenty of time,
dude.
Breeze coming in from the ocean.
What Day is today?
No,
it's not even a month.
No.
Right.
How would you race Nat West Tampa?
I don't know.
My team.
And just break down time.
Do you recognize?
Are Predatory instincts were coming out?
We find so that's my teeth three days
later.
No.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
What about the stakes though?
Here's what are the stakes.
So you sign over your home trial to a
state that we choose.
Yeah,
I went to one of us and then.
But if you win,
if you make the time,
how fucking funny would it be?
Let me just stop you right here.
If one of us,
one the other person's house and let
them live there,
that'd be.
So you got to make the decisions in the
household completely legitimate.
Like we didn't have to put this on
paper,
but bitch,
you know,
I own your house and own your house and
that's why I'm taking the air
conditioner tomorrow.
This is what I was saying is you would,
you'd have,
you'd make some sort of a deal.
You have to pay that other person a
mortgage.
Yeah,
but to do it.
But what about what you could win?
What can I win?
So you could win lifetime supply versus
peanut butter cups like this.
This is the deal already contribution.
Whoever,
whoever wins the other person has to pay
the mortgage plus $100.
Okay?
So you got to pretend that Tommy owns
your house.
If you lose.
So you owe him $100 every month on top
of your mortgage.
That's fucking awesome.
You have to pay him every month.
100 setup auto pay.
You have to realize that.
You have to realize it's because we all
realize,
listen,
bitch,
we own,
you know,
and your house.
Okay?
Whether or not this fucking bullshit,
Zionist government agrees,
we had a god damn deal.
We did like outlaw Josey Wales.
We slid our palms,
we shook hands together and if I win I
own your fucking house.
Okay.
I don't own your house as far as
legally.
Why do we have to go through other
people?
We didn't.
We didn't,
we didn't go through other people for if
you hit it,
you get,
you know,
Tommy owns your fucking house.
Okay.
You know a lot.
Or if I win,
I'd like to.
I'd like to change the locks in your
house and just give it to the rest of
your family.
Tommy's fucking house.
And Tommy's gonna give you 100 times.
Jamie says for a 44 year old male,
this is what the time expected.
What about 26?
Oh my God.
Guys that live in Utah for the average
44 year old male.
You're a better than average.
I know that much.
You're scrolling down.
Good length for that amount of time.
It's better than an average 44 year old
male.
Can you try to break that half marathon?
One 38 female.
What's happened for you?
That solution or solution?
No,
he's got to beat our,
his dad.
He's got to beat our dad beside.
That's easy.
This is interesting.
Twice that long.
This is a female numbers.
Better wages.
Better.
You're angry.
You're not distracted by Dick.
Look,
just look at 7:37,
36.
You think you're gonna beat his dad or
his dad was six months old,
but that's 50 miles per minute were so
really quick pace right here.
You have to pay 7:54.
What's that mean?
Eight minute miles fast.
The average guy gets to it.
Three slash 27.
Forty four year old.
Hold on.
That's amazing.
What a witch.
Marathon and he was just a marathon time
in general.
The distance of the average is three
slash 27.
If you're running and you're training
for that fast,
you should probably should be running
that fast,
but for a dummy like me or birds,
you're not training for a marathon
though,
and you don't run like 70 miles a week.
On average when you.
When you entered four hours,
four hours,
you should do four hours.
You could do for you a lot better than
average.
I flipped.
Now I'm on team.
They're trying to steal money from you,
bro.
You gonna make it four hours.
I'm not going to make it four or five,
five
yoga classes a month.
Ain't shit and we barely got through
that.
Let's be reasonable with each other.
That's an average runner and births
better than an average person to Ari.
It's right in front of our face.
Your Dad.
Anybody can read that?
No.
Whoa.
I'm telling you.
It's going to be.
No,
I couldn't be my dad.
Wait,
what can we do these hours?
Twenty seven minutes.
You can beat that by.
That is.
I could probably.
You might be able to,
man.
No,
no,
no.
You might be able to see the obvious
bet,
but that's.
He's speed walks.
Yeah.
I can speed walk already.
He's going to stop six hours and 20
minutes if we have beer trucks along the
way because.
Oh,
that's on the side.
You can drink.
You can do the work for sure.
Tito's is.
Are you friends with Tito's people sent
me a beautiful name.
Don't worry about it.
Austin,
we find a marathon,
so we do.
We fucking make a marathon,
man.
Howard is a fucking marathon.
Oh yeah,
so you kept pace with anybody?
Yeah.
Well this is even better.
We create our own marathon.
20 six point two of a,
a 26 point two marathon.
We put it in Austin,
Texas or some.
We find a place that we have a place we
could run.
I liked the sound of this.
Now we do a goddamn marathon.
People sign up.
Anybody could sign up,
but Bert has to win.
This motherfucker has to win.
That's the way it.
No,
no,
no marathon.
That's what's the bet.
Bird's gotta win this bet.
Excuse me.
This,
this proposition by beating Ari's dad's
time,
but here's the thing you think you can
man,
but this is like 15 yoga classes you
take.
You can you don't think I'd be six
hours,
might be a 26 million.
How many people do it in?
Less than six hours.
Twice a ton.
About these people,
like their burden?
Ninety five percent.
He's a marathon runner so that drunk and
comedians.
No,
nothing against our deputy is 88.
Stop right now.
Today,
tomorrow morning.
If you say present out in front of the
fucking Barney's beanery stretched for
you.
Let's go.
You want to give you some old school
adidas and you're going to run.
Do you think you'll be able to do it?
That's a little tough right there,
right?
A 500 would be 11 and a half.
Very.
Wow.
Hold on.
What'd already done?
Six,
six,
26.
Another hour.
No,
no,
no.
I mean,
here's the thing.
A mile.
That's where I'm looking at.
This is cute.
That's probably June 14th.
All that's cute.
The real number is you have to figure
out how to finish that thing.
Yeah.
That's the real number is not like how
fast you're going per mile because it's
not realistic because you're going to
get tired and the number is going to
drop off.
Substantially going to hurt.
If you say like seven minute mile,
I could do that.
I could do a seven minute I,
but you used to say that I can do what
we used to say.
Let's not say that anymore because you
were talking about a treadmill,
but if you say on the street you could
do one.
I got that.
I can't do another 25 miles on top of
that.
You can do a five hour marathon.
I know I can get six hours and 26
minutes.
No questions asked if that's what joe
saying.
That's what I'm saying.
What I'm saying,
it's just no way.
You could do all 26 miles the same way.
You could do one mile.
You'll will slow down you.
We'll do one mile like an animal.
I fully believe you could do one mile on
the road in under seven minutes.
If you got fucking crazy.
You had a shot of espresso.
No,
I agree.
That's why I'm looking at the per mile
times because if that,
if you're saying the six hour marathon
is 16 minutes,
do that.
Gets dark around 20 miles will tell you
this from Washington for much of my dead
15 years ago when they did the last
time.
Uh,
we,
we take the metro to different spots.
You can cheer them on and you'd get in
the back of the metro,
go to another place,
chairman again.
And the last spot we're supposed to
cheer them on.
We waited there for like 15 minutes and
we're like,
fuck,
maybe we missed him.
He should've been here by now and we
wait another 10 minutes.
And then he was like,
stumbling down at like mile 25.
It was like,
fuck it.
Zombie walk the rest of the way.
So you telling me,
you,
you're telling me that my hips,
our marathon,
but no,
this is the reality.
So you got to hit a wall.
It feels.
It feels good to tell yourself.
Hold on
this bed.
I'm trying to find a defense to a bet
right now.
Um,
I feel like I'm a negotiated barker.
I'm trying to guess your weight for
sure.
For sure.
There's no question.
Obviously she was stealing money from
you.
It's how much less than 15 yoga classes
is hard but hard.
Yeah.
I'm not speaking.
I'm,
I'm agreeing.
I don't want any.
I'm going to help you with that.
He's trying to beat your voice a lot.
Trying to rob you,
bro.
You can.
You don't.
You think you can do it in less than
five?
What's the pace on a five hour marathon?
Don't look at the Internet,
man.
11 cheat.
Not telling you.
That's part of this.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
Eleven 30 is,
is the pace for a five hour so you can
do that.
Eleven 30 is a tad bit quick.
Quick.
You say now you don't think you could do
a five hour marathon.
You know,
you think you can obviously.
Okay.
But how much time would you need to
prepare?
The average time is three,
27 or 20 sites.
Let's say tomorrow morning you got to
cut.
How much?
What's that?
You got to cut 30 minutes off.
Four and a half hours.
Listen,
we don't.
You stopped crushing the dream.
That's the prototype to production.
That's an interesting question.
Attainable.
What do you think?
Chickens do a runner though,
right?
Right,
right.
No,
I know,
but hold on Jamie.
This is,
this is no insult,
but do you have the mantle gene
camera?
But uh,
you have to.
Courtney doe alter gene that gene.
Yeah,
that's a good.
Now,
could you do though have that Mickey
Mantle do you definitely have.
You definitely have to have a job.
It means return.
You remember the UFC were mayhem fought
where mark layman was yelling out retard
strength.
It was.
It was a thing about like,
like mayhem Miller who's like one of
those underrated mma fighters ever.
He was fucking super physically strong
and him and mark layman who was his
Jujitsu coach is a famous judges who
coach in mma.
They had some weird thing they had.
I don't know,
I never asked them what the code was,
but they would yell out things like do
the Johnny Hendricks.
I think there was a lot of times like
camps will develop codes so that the
other team has no idea what's coming.
When you say the Johnny Hendricks,
it might be like an overhand left.
If you say the George St Pierre,
it might be a superman punch,
like you have these weird code.
So He's yelling out retard strength,
retard strength,
and we're on spike TV,
Spike TV,
and I go,
I think he's yelling out retard to
retard,
retard strength.
He was fighting George St Pierre to you
every time.
Spring for sure.
I think I was surprised.
Cool.
Yeah.
Certain things that Tom and Arrigo and
then we just very simply,
can you hold your breath and swim to one
side of the pool and neither of them
could do it now,
by the way.
Both ways in the pool and I was both
ways.
I'm a champion.
Your are.
You didn't even swim underwater.
He had never done it before my book.
Both my kids were like,
does he know how to swim?
Because he tried to swim on top of the
water,
slap in the water,
and they were like,
Doug,
when you hold your breath,
you dive underneath.
All right.
Now I know.
Now you're acting like.
It's like you're angry.
That doesn't have information that you
have to your Florida boy fighting sharks
swimming away from the sting rays and
shit.
You guys,
what do you think?
I'm curious at,
what do you think you could do tomorrow
morning if you were like,
I'm running the marathon tomorrow?
Definitely six.
Okay,
let's make a bet.
Hold on.
Let's wait tomorrow.
Let's rub something off and I'll give
you an extra half an hour.
Okay?
You want extra half an hour?
I'll give you.
You say you can do it and give me six
hours and 36,000,
30 minutes and I'll give you a $10,000.
You can give that money to the charity
of your choice.
Fuck,
come on man.
Easily do that.
Listen,
a deputy,
you don't have a question.
Six and 30 minutes.
You got to do a full marathon will
figure out a course and if I don't do
it,
if you do it,
if you don't do it,
everybody on the Internet knows.
How about you can't lose,
but if you do do it,
if you can do it by six hours and 30
minutes,
I'll give you an extra 30 minutes.
I will give $10,000.
I'll give $10,000
out anyway.
Well they just make it a whole.
Hold on.
They just make it be like six,
whatever it is that the number.
That's the number.
It's got to be your number one.
Of course.
Ten thousand $100 because I'll throw in
another $100.
About this and if you lose,
if you lose,
if you can't do it in six hours and 30
minutes,
we need you to go to a detox,
like a full on Harvey Weinstein
and you're going to pay for that to pay
for that.
You don't lose anything like Scottsdale,
Arizona.
Be Great.
That might be like vacation.
You got to wear a wire with Dr.
drew,
are you friends with Dr Drew?
Dr Judith wants to help those people
come in and get cameras on.
They'll go refill.
I will throw in 360 assorted candies.
Okay.
I will definitely run a marathon
in six hours and 26 minutes.
Six minutes.
Here's your dad's time.
That's time you're in a race with an 80
year old holocaust survivor.
I'm betting against you.
10 grand.
I'm in.
Good.
Okay.
If I lose,
if I lose,
you're still give them money.
If I lose,
I'll give twice the money if you,
if you will,
so people are going to root against you.
This is.
That's good.
Charitable both ways.
If you go to you don't be selfish.
If you go to [inaudible] dot com,
we'll update.
You can live stream the rest.
There you go.
Alright,
I'll tell you what,
say what,
I'll tell you what we'll give you this
option we can make this is if you win,
I'll,
I'll pay,
I'll give three times as much but if you
lose,
only give two times instead of 10,
I'll make it 20.
And if you win I give 30.
And if you figured out the charity,
if you can do it fast and ours,
Dad,
I give $30,000
to whatever charity you choose or that
if he doesn't,
2020.
So you've reversed the back again.
Well you lose,
you lose.
And people are angry.
Really angry people like people with
head injuries like we're going to give
money to dudes from car.
I have to sign over your house too.
Don't forget about the sign over the
house in a pinky swear pinky swear
thing.
And um,
it's 100 bucks and you owe me 100 bucks
a month.
Yes.
So this is the bet.
Okay?
Here's the way we're going to take time
with dad if he can't read things on
there,
unless they're close.
There's two things and losing.
If you don't beat my dad is one thing,
but if you quit,
that's also another quit.
If you quit,
I give nothing to anybody and I piss in
your mouth.
No factor.
I love that trick by pis.
That's good.
Shot Glass.
No Espresso.
Do you so a double espresso with my pis.
You look like a great athlete.
We'll come up with so much protein.
Listen,
I'll give you some wild elk sausage.
You can eat good food.
This is the other big factor.
The big factor that we're not talking
about.
How soon does it need to do this?
It should be immediately next week.
This is not something you can prepare
for it.
That's not fair because it's not fair to
the people that want money for the
charity.
You have to win this motherfucker on
heart and will I know the kid was
realistic to you can say,
no,
we're the marathon scope.
What's Today's date?
Let's say date,
November.
Where are we up?
Up?
We're going straight to the 10th because
I never even heard of that.
Saturday,
Friday,
Friday in the desert,
and we're going to get there in the
morning.
What else?
Starbucks and say hi to your Baristas
podcast.
You're doing this man.
You know what will be the podcast Billy
Corgan?
Come meet us at the goddamn marathon.
We'll do a podcast with them.
I honestly,
Friday.
What time?
If you want people to cheer you on,
it should be November two shows.
Friday morning you run a marathon in
plenty of time running on better
veterans day.
Back it up.
Hold on.
Back it up,
back it up to that calendar again,
like veteran's day.
That's an extra day long.
People can come to that.
Go back one more.
There's one more.
Want to get crazy?
I can't.
You can not drink for two days.
No,
no,
no.
I can't do Sunday.
Go back to veterans day.
Hold on.
What?
Up?
Back Up.
Back,
back.
Calendar.
Back to the calendar.
Back where we were.
Well,
what about the next one?
Plays the coastline long beach where I
can't go back up.
Go back.
I'll take you on.
I'm in Tampa,
that on the 11th.
I'm so confident I want to give them a
couple of weeks.
Ari,
show me what we got.
Show me what we got.
I want to give them a couple of weeks or
so.
Marina,
Turkey trot.
That's Thanksgiving week.
It's thanksgiving,
thanksgiving Turkey.
This thanksgiving day I.
It feels right to me.
How about the field to do it as a fat
fuck after that's given.
He can't do.
He can't do that.
I'm running in Tampa in Tampa that we
had,
so the Thursday fun camp.
You're getting so much time to train it.
That's no,
no,
no.
Go back up.
Your Marina Turkey trot or feeling
stuffed?
They're both on Thanksgiving or the day
after thanksgiving.
Black Friday.
You want to do Friday?
The day after thanksgiving.
Thanksgiving.
There'll be giving.
When we thought it started this weight
loss challenge.
I started.
Perfect.
Perfect time.
She really started thanksgiving.
Yeah.
I started the day after.
I will do this.
Why do you of carbs feel so good?
It's going to be rough.
I have my cars feel good.
It feels like I shouldn't,
I shouldn't.
This is my most recent thoughts that I'm
willing to run an extra two miles a day
to eat.
Like Shit.
Yeah,
Spaghetti.
So let's,
let's tear this bet.
Telomere length that people are
concerned with.
I want people rooting for you to quit.
So I would say those 3:30,
if you do it 2010,
if you just lose a second four,
nine,
four and a half from our three and a
half mile loop.
You just keep running in a circle.
Oh,
he'll never make it.
What we do,
we just set up coolers along the way.
We hire some bikini checks.
That's nice.
There's all nice things that you'd hire
some girls with a stinky feet,
like getting off their shifts.
Watches were nylon socks.
A loop.
I'd be better for me Jamie,
maybe this Friday.
The Friday after Thanksgiving in Long
Beach was there and it's just a loop.
Jamie,
it looks like it's on the three and
three quarter miles out.
By the time you got to go down one.
Then the turnaround.
Come right back.
Let me ask you an honest question.
Do you think you could run drunk?
Yeah,
for sure.
You've brought drunk drunk faster.
That's a bad dad.
No,
this is the real bad.
Right?
We're catching on now.
I'm thinking about that now.
It feels right now.
Harley back the hardest coming back.
Drunk.
Drunk,
drunk,
drunk defined it.
Just start drinking.
Getting hammered.
Hammered for me.
How about I have to fucking drink with
you when I go do.
We're ready to go.
And then you run guys.
Thirteen years doing speed in America.
They might have shot them up with that
or was that the university saying,
look at that kid.
That kid probably got a hammer for a
dick.
Treadmill.
Foreign on hero.
Wait a minute.
Get on the treadmill.
You can beat Res Dad's time in the
marathon and survive and survive the
helicopter and you have to drink
throughout the day.
This way you have to do it.
You have to fly into Dubai and just fly
back.
That's it.
No,
no.
I'm a one trick of mine.
Once I will,
I'll do this one of where I can drink 26
drinks,
26 drinks in six hours.
You can't.
You can totally die.
Wait a minute,
I'll get you a motorcycle.
Listen,
I don't like to hear any of this bitch
ass talk.
Who is this guy doing it in the cold?
Chugging a beer and then jay drink one
every mile.
It's a court and he did a sub two hour a
half marathon.
Marathon obviously got fucking making
male jeans for sure.
For sure.
Jon Snow Jeans and he just drank a beer
every mile so it shows them stopping in
a second.
This is great.
Fucking Gopro on his head the whole
time.
Hilarious areas.
What a savage.
Passing everybody
passing people.
Drop them on a bike.
He's biking along side.
It will get better every.
Every mile.
It's him passing everybody.
Wow.
That's incredible.
Hammered already in shape,
right?
Much of a detriment isn't bad.
They used to do it during the Tour de
France.
He is shotgunning them.
Number two.
That's a good lesson.
In physics.
He put the glove on those hands.
They'll get cold because he's got his
hands up in the air too.
He's running with his hands in the air,
passing quitters.
Feel like somebody just tried to lecture
him like,
you really shouldn't be doing that.
Who just like see you later.
Here's what I realized
to bring this back home to base.
Here's what I realized during sober
October,
October.
I don't need alcohol,
but I like it.
It's great.
Great,
great grandpa need weed.
But I like it.
Yeah,
I liked him.
I like it.
Kitten.
It's for me,
it's changed how my circuitry works,
you know,
it's changed how I like uh,
how I communicated with people and I
think that there's a thing about alcohol
is like you pay for it.
No,
he definitely paid for it physically.
But you,
there's like an exchange.
The thing is to figure out what that
exchange is like,
what's it,
what's it worth?
Getting really lit and having an amazing
time and hugging your friends,
telling him you love him and just hold
it and let.
Let me tell you something.
I think to this day about one of the
Times you and I got drunk together in
Texas.
We first started going on the road
together.
We'd be going on the road together like
a couple of years and we were in like a
honky tonk bar.
Remember that,
and was it Houston or Austin?
I feel.
I don't know why I thought it was
Louisville or something,
somewhere in Texas,
sexist and we were hammered and were
just hugging.
I'm like,
dude,
I have so much fun hanging out with you.
And you said the same thing and like we
could say things that you always knew
that I appreciate you as a comedian and
you always knew that we were friendly
and we had some gigs together,
but it took us getting drunk too.
Hug it out,
go job.
We're having so much fun.
I'm pretty sure I cried.
We did it.
Yeah,
you definitely cried.
So that's not like I didn't want to
bring you up.
I'm crying right now.
I really am crying right now because I
knew you were.
You're a good dude man.
You were funny as fuck.
And I knew what you were because I had
been.
Were you were,
you were,
you were at the launching pad like God
damn.
Is this happening like what's happening?
My fucked is it going to work out,
you know,
this does that weird moment
and you know,
and I'd already been there before and we
were friends and I was like,
dude,
you gonna you gonna work,
you're gonna do it 100 percent.
And then we were drunk together and we
were talking about that moment.
I think about that all the time,
man.
I really do.
Really?
I do now when you're killing it,
I think about.
I'm crying.
I think about that shit all the time.
I do.
You don't have to see someone that you
like when I met you in 2007,
I mean you'd obviously been doing comedy
a couple of years but you were,
you were trying to figure it out,
you know.
Well I think about that.
I think about it too because like,
you know,
it's hard,
like people don't realize the
opportunity when,
when you,
when you kind of reach down and you
bring somebody along for that,
it's hard sometimes to convey like your
gratitude,
you know,
so like that was one of those times were
like in.
So when you're sober you go like,
do thanks so much.
Like how many times you're going to say,
you know what I mean,
like you go,
I really appreciate it,
but when it goes back to like what the
alcohol kind of opens up for you is like
you let down your guard,
you let down that you let the
vulnerability come to the surface.
And I think that was really for me
because I've thought about it.
It's like the expression of gratitude
overwhelmed me because I realized how
lucky I was like you know,
you and any number of people can bring
along wherever they want on the road
with them.
So like that for me was just like,
I couldn't believe how lucky I was to be
able to travel real shows,
you know,
do real shows with like these really
appreciative audiences and like you're
bringing me along and like I feel like a
like an equal.
It was overwhelming to me.
You know,
it was overwhelmed.
You,
you are an equal.
We're all equal.
It's like we're all just like different
parts of the road.
Yeah.
The road is the same road.
No,
it is going in,
but there's lessons,
there's lessons from that,
you know,
like there's lessons that people are
willing to learn about themselves.
They gotta they gotta be willing to
learn it themselves to tell you,
but you have to know it encouraged,
you know,
it does.
Just living through it encourages you to
pass it along.
So that's kind of the coolest part is
because like,
I mean I've really tried to,
to mimic that.
I bring,
I brought a bunch of guys most recently,
Josh Potter is this really funny dude
from buffalo and I brought them on most
of these dates and you know,
like a hookup that can't take care of
his travel to the ice house.
Yeah.
And he's a,
he's a great.
He just moved here.
He's just really funny.
Really,
really funny.
You know red though,
one of the only times I ever cried on
the podcast was I'm listening to a
podcast where you were talking about
your and I relationship.
It's one of the few times I ever cried,
like listening to a podcast.
I was like,
wow,
this is like heavy emotional where
you're talking about like me and you
going on the road.
Like in the early days,
it was pretty fun.
It was amazing,
man.
It was your podcast where we did the
buck hunter podcast is the beginning of
the end where we were talking.
You were talking about our relationship
when you first started out,
you know?
Yeah.
It was good to go from open mics to be
able to see like,
like you said,
just like,
oh,
this is like a real crowd.
It's here.
It's so big.
People.
Some people never even get a taste of
that and then you'd come back.
I'd always try to go back on Sunday
night to the potluck.
Excuse me.
It was.
No,
it was Sunday then and then it was like
to go back to dose of reality.
This sucks,
but I know I can do it now.
Yeah,
but you,
you all knew.
Everybody knows they kinda can do it.
That's why they're trying to do it,
but you need to.
Someone who's ahead of you,
like holds a flashlight.
It's like,
come on,
take a look at this shit.
Come on.
We're all the same.
Keep going,
keep going.
Like when you took me to laugh and
limited and I bombed in front of you for
like our.
He didn't know you from the time where I
first met you to you having your own
comedy central show to having your own
Netflix special,
which is double special.
Special two hours you had to do to you
pretentious.
Fuck.
Or 45.
40th five enough.
Still half hour more than anybody.
But it was still.
It was like wow.
Yeah.
It's weird when you can set your reality
one way and then it just slowly change
over time.
Yeah,
and that's what we.
It seems counterintuitive because you
seem like you're trying to hold down the
competition.
The problem is if you hold down a
competition,
you inevitably hold on yourself.
You don't.
You don't mean to.
You're the barstow lower.
It's not just that.
It's like you're looking at it the wrong
way.
So one of the reasons why I always took
killers on the road,
the other tough dude I used to take Joey
Diaz,
we took Duncan,
we took Ari.
Like I always took murderers on the
road.
Anybody following bringing electively,
bringing Joe.
He is.
It was me up for the longest time.
Me Then Diaz the rogue,
a great show.
And then it was in Austin.
Diaz goes,
Hey,
I'm going to go first today.
They're going to go last second.
I mean I didn't know it was just he
likes to go to sleep,
but then I was like,
am I being punished?
What did I do?
Yeah,
I didn't do anything.
It's terrible place to be following joey
in less.
It's not.
The thing is if you embrace.
It was a good crowd.
I'm the number one Joey Diaz Fan in the
world other than his wife and his
daughter.
It's like there's like everybody else is
like,
if you might be the same but you
definitely don't love him more than I
do.
So for me it was like taking that gun in
the road.
It's like I want to see him.
That's the only way you learn that doing
stand up long enough.
If you embrace the person in front of
you,
like you embrace it,
that like you enjoy it.
You can,
you can,
you can go back and yet you can feel
what people feel is you being nervous
and fearful if you're like,
this is awesome,
dude.
I've been there.
I mean I followed Jim.
Brewer wants when I was like 26,
25,
changed my fucking life.
He ate.
He crushed so hard and I ate so many
dicks.
I choked to death like the for the rest
of my life I will never get a feel as
bad as it felt then.
And I was like 24 or 25,
whatever the fuck I was.
I might've been younger.
I didn't know shit and Jim and I were
just starting out and Jim was the Middle
Act.
He was the headliner,
but just because I have a good manager
because he got really like I can't
follow Jim Breuer back then.
I just couldn't.
I just,
I did.
We did like three shows I think.
I think we did like two shows Friday and
one show Saturday were followed up and
then the second show Saturday was so
bad.
It was so bad.
I went down so hard,
maybe a seriously considering not too
uncommon anymore.
I ate so many dicks.
This guy looked at me in the audience
and he goes,
do not fucking funny.
Oh my God.
And I'm like,
if I'm being honest with myself,
he's right.
Yeah.
It was horrible,
man.
I was dressed like a fucking Quito,
trying to get some posts.
He had a disco disaster headshot to some
of the best old heads are the worst.
I had a torn ACL,
super depressed.
My girlfriend dumped me and just moved
to New York.
It was a combination of all sorts of
things and then brewer,
flame thrower,
Shit.
He used to do this bit about coming home
drunk and meeting his mom and his mom
turned into a monster.
It was so good.
He was crushing so hard.
He'll be like,
he,
you know,
brewer has crazy facial expressions.
He'd be like stumbling drunk.
He was killing it.
So
you must have followed some savages in
New York that you can follow,
right?
Burt,
you're talking to me to bring you back
in.
He's your friend.
Fucking shit.
I'm just listening.
I'm just saying I feel like I'm like in
a plane.
No,
but I know that you were,
you moved to New York.
You're like you had like a good set and
tallahassee.
Like what?
You're following fucking pros some
nights,
right?
Yeah.
I went to the end of every night at
Boston comedy club.
Yeah,
but I don't know,
I just,
I felt like if you embrace the energy,
you could always move it forward.
I remember having a follow Billy Gardell
on the Jamison comedy tour and billy was
like a road destroyer,
just like he would have everything.
I remember when we used to follow,
when we used to work with Jay,
Jay would do an hour and then I close it
and do 30,
which is by the way,
the craziest fucking thing I've ever
heard and I didn't hear it until last
week when you toe.
When he told me that the order that they
would wait.
Did you say Jay would do an hour and
then he would close close.
Why would he?
But it was,
it was.
It was after he had come back from not
doing like,
he didn't always do
that,
but he took time off of standup.
You're a good guy.
So then he came.
I liked about you,
Tom.
He came,
came back.
By the way,
I'm just fucking hammered.
This is what happened.
He came back after like not doing
standup.
So either.
I'm not saying that either,
but I'm saying that I've never heard
that in my life.
Like I'm going to do like a Joe Rogan at
the Belko.
Then I'm going to have a Haitian.
Was trio.
Go on.
Do a half an hour after me.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It was,
it was,
it was rude to him.
It was like.
But it was in the like.
I'm like,
I haven't done stand in two years,
so I know what's going to happen.
Tosh does a brilliant thing.
Tosh host shows and so does Russell.
Russell,
Russell Peters in friends bring a gang
of funny shorts when like he ensures
that everybody comes out.
We're going to have a good old time,
Russell.
Just one hour in the middle is a weird
different way to do it.
It's a different way to do it.
Our book,
right?
Who's to say what's the right way to do
it?
Uh,
other comments?
I guess I'll tell you what,
other comedians who say nobody,
nobody.
You can do whatever you want does works
beautifully.
And Russell's like,
same thing for sure.
And he hosts really,
I've never seen that.
If he doesn't host,
he brings like a ton of dudes on the
road with them.
Be like Ian Edwards,
like murderers,
you know,
it brings a ton of times.
If you feel like doing 18 minutes,
you can totally join three.
And I feel like I'm here to see Russell
and his friends.
It's like these guys are like stamp of
Russell Peters,
you know,
he knows you're going to see some killer
comedians.
They're going to go up.
Doesn't care by the way.
He's another one.
Fuck,
what if you could like that shit.
You could set a fucking stick of
dynamite off and then he'll walk out
there and they'll forget who the fuck
you were in media.
Russell Peters love him.
Russell Peters in my mind,
embodies like,
there's like,
I don't want to do this to you because
you're here,
but there's two people that embody like
what you should do,
right?
If you can actually do it,
we should do like what you did.
Like when he vanished for four months to
fucking Asia.
What you do,
somebody brings you an ad and you're
like,
yeah,
that's not cool.
Fuck that.
At some of those ads you got to fuck
those ads.
The whole comedy central thing where
you're like,
Yay,
I'm going to go.
Good luck with the show.
I'm not doing it anymore.
Not many people will do that,
but it's like you and Russell,
like Russell doesn't give a fuck.
He.
He could look.
Russell has the love of,
first of all,
a billion people forever.
Forever.
About a billion.
A billion.
He's bigger than me now.
He's bigger than any bundle.
Russell has the love of a billion
people.
Yeah.
I mean it's him and Aziz and as easy as
a bit smug because he is these
diseases on Gq is in Paris.
Why come to Bali motherfucker?
What's going on?
You're talking to me.
No,
Russell Russell can't go wrong and he
knows he can't go wrong so he doesn't
give a fuck.
Like the two of you guys don't get like.
It's like all these things are bar
setters.
Des is a bar set or for us Dunkin's Abar
Center because he's so weird.
He's very different.
He's a par center.
He's a bar center as far as like
psychedelic consciousness exploration,
understanding Thompson.
He's just panicking bottles problem.
So maybe maybe he's not the one that
champ champ could hold his water.
You've got to be free man.
I'd like when dudes shaved their heads
like when they give in because it makes
me like we're all together tomorrow.
As long as I can.
Let me see what you got.
It's all right.
It's curly.
Why?
Hold onto it man.
I'm telling you to waste time.
Hold onto it.
Bert,
I wish I could go back to me on news
radio to my head back.
I would've been like,
fire me,
I'm free.
I remember when you're committed to the
full sleeves,
people like you,
you're not going to work on TV anymore
and you're like,
right.
You and I had a conversation and I was
like,
that's why I'm doing it.
Got fear factor again with full sleeves,
both slaves.
They didn't care.
It's not a big deal,
but when I,
when I decided to do it,
I was like,
I like art.
I'm like,
why is skin like regular skin so good?
Why is it so important?
And I was like,
there's a certain aspect that I like
about tattoos.
You're embracing the fact that you're
have a finite nature.
Who are punker well,
you know you're going to die.
It's like it's not forever because
you're not forever.
It's a concept.
No,
no,
I'm joking.
They're cool.
They look good.
Well,
this is.
I got one guy who did both of them.
His name is Aaron Dellavedova from grew
tattoo in San Diego.
The guy's the shit.
He's awesome.
Would you add to them?
You will.
I was shocked you didn't have him on
your chest?
No.
If half your chest,
like just very spacey here.
No,
I'm feeling uncomfortable.
You guys are judging me?
No,
no.
When we did yoga,
what would you think of?
Have like maybe like some uh,
dragonflies.
Like,
what's that dude from blink one?
Eight?
No,
that's the other guy.
What's the band?
Crazy town?
No,
no,
no.
The really handsome guy.
Mark.
Uh,
he went onto entertainment.
Oh,
mark hoppus for cigarette?
No sugar ray.
Yeah.
My progress.
He's got like cute little doves.
I thought like the Korean flag over like
something like that.
I would have got it.
And when I was 18,
when I was fucking full bore and tuck
window,
I would have gotten a Korean flag.
One hundred percent.
I want a tattoo.
That shit.
Yeah.
I used to count and Korean.
I teach classes in Korean.
All the techniques.
Learning Korean.
I don't,
I don't know how to speak Korean at all,
but I can count.
Can It really?
Yeah.
On a dual said ned doors.
You do?
Yeah.
I,
I used to be able to do it.
He's just drinking water or used to go
to counseling 100.
But I forgot,
I used to know all the names for
taekwondo techniques.
Delivery.
Yeah.
Yup.
Chuggy.
Yeah.
Like everything you teach class,
like every time you teach job and
everybody was like half like stand
there.
So everything was done in Korean.
Yeah,
it was intense.
Man Drove,
knocked drunk so to finally never,
never dropped off.
Yeah.
I got nervous when you said you took.
I'm just being honest because Aryan.
I actually had a discussion about it.
I got legitimately nervous when we were
on the podcast.
You said you drink six doubles a day?
I got super nervous,
but this is why I got there a lot.
It is a lot,
but this is why I got nervous.
Not just because I love you and I want
you to be healthy,
but also because I'm like,
I don't think you need to do that.
Like if you had a drink a day or two
drinks a day or three drinks a day,
he'd probably be fine.
Like you're.
You give your liver enough slack?
No,
you're eventually but not right away.
You wouldn't get drunk.
Yeah.
But when you get into that neighborhood
of six doubles a day,
like,
dude,
you're talking about 12 drinks of
alcohol or you're fine,
you're fine just because you want to win
100 bucks.
But you couldn't get drunk.
Yeah.
Could double sales in a single Tito's?
Are you drunk off two shots in New
Orleans?
Oh really?
Yeah,
there's for sure.
Sure.
I got so high the first day back.
Me and Owen Benjamin did a poc high.
Yeah.
I got a pretty.
Like,
I'm pretty toasty in.
I've just got regular high.
I got nerve.
Anything different?
Not Different for you at all?
Well,
the first time I got high alone,
not drinking.
We drank and we added some,
some bloods and stuff.
People around bloods I think even you
out because it's kind of a stimulant.
Like I didn't smoke blunts until I hung
out with Charlie Murphy.
Really?
Charlie used to smoke legit blunts,
like kid,
his cousin rich who had rolled these
legit blondes out of Swisher sweets.
Take out the tobacco leaves like a
little bit in and then roll it up with
weed and then lick it down.
And we would get
tobacco.
Yeah.
Nervous.
Hi.
Terrifying high.
He was one of the hardest deaths that I
ever had to deal with.
Really?
Yeah.
Because I wish I contacted him more.
I wish we got together more,
but we were always on the road.
Like that guy's a man.
Like he was a,
he was a real man,
like,
like he never had any like weird shit
yet to work through.
He was,
he always held his mud,
like trolley was different man.
He was like a guy who didn't come into
celebrity at all until his forties.
So he's developed.
He was a real man that love that guy.
So it's one of those guys,
like sometimes you get,
you get tired,
you just doing too many things and you
for you forget to concentrate on people
that you've run into in your life that
you're like,
God damn.
That guy was a good dude.
Like Charlie Murphy was a good
motherfucker.
I can't have joke onstage.
The talked about it wasn't trying to,
but he was like,
he goes,
people say to me,
you know that people yell out China,
Hey,
hey.
He goes,
hey man,
instead of a bother you,
it's someone just yells out,
Charlie Murphy.
Every time he seen he goes,
no.
He goes,
because for the first time in my life it
wasn't like,
hey you Eddie Murphy's brother.
Right.
And even laugh about it onstage,
like slap as an a and that was real for
him.
Sure.
We got to experience a guy who like went
through a whole life as a grown man and
was approaching middle age before fame
kicked in and he only had like a 10,
15 year ride before he died.
He was a good dude man.
The magnitude of like,
you know that show,
but like particularly like to sketches.
Like that's how big an impact those two
sketches he was,
he would just play that.
I remember when he started a tour,
you know when you go to the clubs,
they played it before.
Oh,
just that,
that like the teaser that he's coming,
he's coming next week or two weeks and
then will be just like a little bit of
like the Rick James Sketch or the print
separate and fucking all the shows sold
out.
You know what,
man,
he didn't,
I really feel like there's a
developmental process that you could
apply to like UFC fighters and even
stand up comedians.
If you take a guy who's got some
potential,
then you make them fight Anderson Silva
and his prime when he was 20 years old
and it gets knocked unconscious.
He's never going to be the same again.
Yeah.
And I almost feel like it's the same
thing with comedians.
I don't care if you're 40 or 50 or 60 or
20 to go on stage and eat dick is
horrific.
And what Charlie did was he went from
being a guy who was on the Chappelle
show to hosting a show with other
comedians like don l and I and Dave and
whoever was on the show and talking a
little like,
Hey,
what's up?
And instead of just continuing to do
that,
he started headlining because that where
the money,
that's where the money was like no open
mic famous.
So bringer shows,
no female MC and dude,
we did 22 dates together,
22 days together and we swapped who went
back and forth like he had lined one had
one,
1:00
PM,
one line one and he just dug his seat.
Who has either the ones you were on?
Well,
I swapped but I did three.
I did Irvine,
San Diego,
and Phoenix.
And so damn be different.
Different people in different nights.
But I saw.
Yeah,
I saw him.
I saw him struggle one night.
Must have been running.
Oh my God.
And then I saw him actually do really
well the next night.
Really?
Yeah.
Well if you can get on the middle spot,
he could do pretty good.
He was a funny dude,
but it's just not.
It's not a good team member.
It's not the right place to put some
money in his mega millions joke.
Do you remember if he was doing that?
He had a bunch of great job.
Great.
A bunch of great jokes,
man.
He was a funny and and offstage.
Maybe one of the funniest guys of all
time.
He took me to dinner on that thing,
which I didn't expect and I don't think
rich wanted me to come and,
and like we went out to dinner and he
was,
yeah,
a murphy,
his cousin's cousin.
But he was as.
He was like,
what you like?
That show was fresh.
That was,
you know.
And like he,
he was telling stories.
He,
he was,
he told the story that I texted you to
ask him when you had them on.
I asked him if he blue Gill.
Gill fucking Mike Tyson.
Tiger story.
Good story.
Tyson's house.
He a pet tiger.
No one want to get out of the limousine.
Tracy,
did you ever hear the busboy story?
Which ones are Charlie Murphy?
When is Eddie?
Let him borrow clothes?
No.
Oh my God.
That's so funny.
Just I,
I'll never do it justice.
And it's so good when he tells it.
You got to tell you.
GotTa tell it because they're not
considered available online.
So you got to find it.
So see if you can find,
you know,
you're never gonna be able to find it
because it's in snoop dogg's podcast.
Oh alright,
bet.
I bet someone's put it on Youtube.
I know Bert Kreischer did.
I fucking grabbed it today.
Died.
And I was like,
this is one of the best stories I've
heard.
That's right.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's where I saw it.
Yeah.
I don't know how I put it online,
but anyway,
to make,
he gets,
he comes out of the navy and he comes
out to La and then they all want to go
out to a party.
But all these guys navy close,
he's just out and Eddie's the biggest
fucking movie star.
You're on earth,
right?
So his brother is like,
and it's young prime time and it's this
it.
Oh,
I'll just play this play
outfit days when Shit was high with
Eddie had a flat outfits.
Did you ever like take that?
Oh Man.
You know what?
He went to take my shirt off and he has
one of the most brutal,
brutal experiences.
Outfits because I first got out the
navy,
I came out to la.
My brother was huge,
right?
So we hang it down.
He had different type of show,
business clothing he was supposed to
having.
He was a showman.
Everybody knew he was,
so he happened to own a glitter bus.
Boy.
Jack from the boys are back in town.
Yeah.
You get a bus boy,
Jack,
and we was going out to the.
It was a century 21 over there.
Then there was a club over.
I said,
Yo man,
you want to wear this jacket?
So the jacket was a green glitter
busboys Jack.
I'm trying to get my stamp coming out.
The Navy I had was uniform.
I put the bus boy jacket and it had my
chains and all that,
and then we went to the and I thought I
was going to be walking through the
cloud and everybody goes,
yeah,
Ms Dot Eddie Murphy.
Murphy,
who's at behind the bus?
What could do?
Don't know.
He looked like he's.
I was like,
Yo,
man.
And Jackie started burning kerosene on
executive lit this shit up.
When he died I used to enjoy and I knew
this to be a tom because you guys a tour
with him.
He was like,
you don't know how funny is.
He thought he could fight Billy Gill.
No,
no,
no.
He said that johnny,
Johnny Gill,
we're looking at the screen and his ass
because he's like,
you think could fuck you up,
and I was like,
yeah,
I know right now.
I was like,
yeah man,
he's a professional,
but he would ruin your life.
And he was like,
Johnny Gill thinks he could fuck them
up.
That was like what?
And then he started telling the story
about how he was hanging out with johnny
and Johnny Gill just looked at the TV
and was like,
I could fuck up to Oscar de la Hoya.
And he was like,
what are you talking about man?
In the way that child.
He's like asking the hood with rearrange
the whole way.
You Shit look man.
And Johnny Gale was like,
Nah,
he's pretty.
He's like,
that don't mean that
shit.
Fucking punch a hole in your face.
Pretty.
Charlie Murphy was at dinner with Maury
Smith who is a former UFC heavyweight
champion of the world.
I haven't salivary who's a former UFC
fighter who actually had a move that we
started around the salivary.
Remember Ivan?
Ivan had a move where it was what wasn't
really his mood,
but it was a move that he was one of the
first guys to tap somebody with it where
he got the triangle from the back and
elevated his hips to like press down
into your back.
Guys were tapping out from like getting
triangled from behind.
We started realizing how dangerous that
movie.
So I haven't salivary is like a time
tested warrior,
right?
So Maurice Smith,
former UFC heavyweight champion,
Ivan salivary,
Charlie Murphy is explaining why y'all
Niggas don't know about the Chicago
Ridge hand.
He's explaining some particular like
martial arts move with.
It's called the rich hand.
It's a strike and I don't know what the
Chicago rich hand was,
but Charlie was insistent that no one
was trying out the Chicago Ridge hand
and MMA and that people could do it and
like they were laughing and Charlie was
like,
no,
fuck you.
He goes,
you tell me.
I'll hit you in the head with a ridge
hand.
Red Ban took a picture and I put it up
on my instagram.
It's Charlie Murphy standing up.
No worries.
Smith.
And the Ivan Salad and then I like this.
I got his hand up chopping someone on
the bridge there notes.
I'm a hit you on the bridge.
He,
Yo,
dude.
We were quite fancy fucking ruth.
Chris steakhouse somewhere like that's
the natural thing.
I mean like I looked at him and I go
just him.
How it hasn't been the first time you
were sitting on those ship House that.
And he showed any told that uh,
that's it.
That's it.
That's the photo.
That guy on the right hand corner is my
is Marvin said that's Ivan salivary and
right to his left or Charlie Murphy's,
right.
Go for the black guy.
That's Maury Smith.
That's more his forte.
That is the former UFC heavyweight
champion of the world.
That's trolley.
Talking about.
Look how wide his eyes are.
Look at the smile underneath his left
arm.
Look at that guy laughing.
Everybody's.
I'm wishing I was in this photo but I
was crying too.
But I was probably under the table at
this point just because I did that
podcast with Joe.
It was like the same sort of situation
under the table crying at that point
like,
I love you guys,
but I gotta head out.
We're all going to go.
This is the point like Ralphie,
like Charlie,
like everybody,
we're all going to go.
You know what?
The quicker you realize that,
the quicker you get that in your head,
the more you'll enjoy this weird time.
We're in the sunshine right after the
rain.
It doesn't last.
It's good time to be a comic.
It's a good time to be alive,
but as the human race,
as a person,
all of us,
there's no.
No one gets out alive.
No one quicker.
We remember that.
The better we'll all be does not work.
I was cut off a couple of times.
All we heard is this is the end.
We're all going to go.
Did you see it?
You hear it did go through clip to.
He asked me to put it back together.
We're all going to go.
You know?
I mean we,
we miss charlene,
we miss everybody that we know that's
gone.
It's gonna.
You did your fucking thing that tried to
make more people cry.
Your outro and Christina's about Ralph.
If Jesus didn't even know you had.
I didn't know you had emotions in you
like that.
That was you.
You gave like a touching tribute men to
Ralphie?
Yeah.
I didn't want to listen to it.
Yeah,
you did as a good guy.
He was gay as fuck,
man.
How Gay was it?
Super Gay.
It about punished my asshole.
Yeah,
felt punished.
It was like eight guys just jacking off
when you're belching.
Johnson was like a,
a place where they like.
Okay,
back it up.
What is like where the line was crossed
and they brought it back?
Yeah.
There's not like a lot of belching
videos out there anymore.
No,
no.
It was a bit.
It was a thing about four or five years
ago.
That was that fat bird pusher.
Four or five years ago,
people talked about felting.
Now.
Now people are like,
let's just preserve our own sanity.
Oh yeah.
That's perfect.
Just now
today.
This is getting long.
Okay.
Listen,
we didn't come to a conclusion.
We didn't decide we going to be my dad
drunk.
Yeah,
you have to beat his dad.
You have to be drunk and you have to do
it in six hours and 26,
26,
27.
We don't have any stake in this.
Like physically.
I'm uncomfortable with that because I
feel like we're bullying.
Oh No,
no,
no reward.
If you can do it.
No,
there's no reward.
We'll talk about later.
Go to figure this out.
Do you think we fucked up on the last
one but not for sure.
I say will chip in and get you that.
Fuck it.
No poverty.
Fucking motorcycle.
Listen to your wife doesn't listen to my
podcast or grilled cheese or we're
wrapping up right now.
I'm going to have a drink.
Does your wife.
There's no way your wife was going to
listen this deep end.
This is my thought.
How about we the the is for the
motorcycle and we keep that bitch here.
As I said,
no.
Can you imagine in a few years kitchen
riding with your daughters?
Yeah.
I can't wait.
Open road.
One seat already know.
I mean,
she's also motorcycling because you guys
are fucking bad ass parent taught her
to.
That's almost the rush that you would
feel if you survived would almost be
worth it.
So we got to get that motorcycle for
you.
The Friday after Thanksgiving,
the longest.
Melissa etheridge.
How about a drink every two miles?
No,
otherwise wait,
hold on,
hold on.
Melissa etheridge convinced she's not
going to die.
Every time she gets on a plane.
You got to feel like that.
Every time you get on that,
Barbara,
we're talking about three different
conversations.
Melissa Etheridge,
alive or not,
she'd been in a plane crash or not.
By the way,
this is exactly how that last podcast
without realizing anything,
and then the bet was started.
Yeah,
but it was great.
That was great.
Okay.
Let's wrap it up in two minutes.
Should we all run this marathon
together?
That's impossible now possible.
Oh No.
I can never do it all drunk.
Drunk and stoned.
This is what we did.
We do so incredibly physically
intensive,
but we do it hammered.
I mean hammered.
If we're doing it as a group,
I'm in.
That'd be fun.
I'm saying I'm not going to run a
marathon every two and a half miles.
I feel like adopt.
No one has a tolerance.
Fucking pressure has.
I don't care.
I'd rather just do it.
Quit drinking gatorade.
Event wise.
Not Jerking off in the bushes.
Just you are going to marathon.
Yeah.
Melons with the marathon before we bike
next to him every to rollerskate five
miles.
We drank a shot of Tequila rollerskating
through a marathon.
Definitely.
If it was flat,
flat,
flat.
No,
it's downhill.
I mean it might be that one.
That was a track.
You don't.
You don't think he can beat you on
roller skates.
Who are you?
Let's make the bet.
Tom Cannot beat me.
You've got to wear fruit for.
Wait a minute on what?
Fuck you can use to go rollerskating
parties like every other fucking was a
speed skater.
That's that.
That's different than what you're
saying,
but here's the thing.
You run growers,
we agreeing on the same unless he runs
out of steam,
which is very lucky when that is
salaries you win.
How would you when you quit?
That's six miles rollerskating on an on
to walk.
Then rollerskate around.
Do you ever rollerskate around the elap
and you're like,
I'm exhausted.
I'm going to take a break for three
straight hours,
are going to do that four straight
hours.
I said,
ain't shit man.
I mean,
I've been like,
oh my God.
Oh my God.
Ankles get tired.
His thighs will get burnt.
Oh,
do this and when you have the slightest
uphill and he's walking in,
how are we gonna do it was a flat track
to this track.
Jamie the Turkey stuff on the beach like
right on the roller skating marathon
back to snoop dogg.
If it's uphill,
it's slightly uphill and it's.
But it's much more exhausting to
rollerskate uphill by the way.
It's so much easier on the downhill.
Sliding downhill.
The other West Skating Twenty six point
two miles,
42 point two kilometers is undoubtedly.
Undoubtedly he's skating and roller
blades or roller skates.
This is roller.
The roller blades requested.
Kiana skates are fair,
but roller blades aren't fail.
Ever Seen Bret Ernst Act.
That's roller skating.
Roller skating.
Yeah.
That guy could beat you in a run.
I think your mic here under hearing me,
it's easier on roller blades.
Roller skates is the hardest time with
four wheels roller.
Tom Skeet speedskating.
They do go fast.
I'm rolling too fast.
It's easy.
I did my Uber's here.
How about this?
Bet on Tom.
If you are on a scale or skates,
you have to beat him by half.
Not just beat up.
Beat up.
Just being beaten is easy,
but real acquit.
He's confident.
You think real quick.
Do you know I'm going right now to buy
fucking another pair of roller skates.
He ain't gonna run it and I thought this
through for me
and I wondered if I could beat myself
rollerskating a marathon and I was like,
dude,
you're forgetting.
I'm not going to tell you why I have
fatigue.
You're,
you're,
you're choosing.
The fatigue is totally different than
jogging.
Yeah,
like yeah,
you go a little faster and you get some
downhills,
but you also have appeals,
Bro.
I got pink rollerskates.
Courtney doe.
Walter ran 238 miles and you're telling
them you could rollerskate those?
I'm no,
I'm telling you it's like a mountain.
That's the way you can roll it out.
I think it's a fair.
I'm quitting.
Is a real possibility.
Cars here.
I'm going home.
Start paying them down.
No,
you are.
You know you're going to listen.
They're going to be in my role as kids.
I think you can.
If you don't quit,
you'll quit.
He gets a razor rollerskates.
Let's and let's not be hasty.
This is a long podcast.
Let's think this.
This has real merit to another podcast.
Ours going back to New York.
We can skype,
we can skype it.
Local board.
We have a skype or we it.
Okay,
so we'll skype.
It will have.
The three of us will get together.
We'll skype Ren.
We'll put them on the big screen.
We'll work this out special now and this
is what I feel.
I feel like the first time it worked out
amazing.
We,
we,
we didn't really have it ironed out
before.
We ran off to our 15 yoga classes in
our.
No alcohol and no stove.
We didn't have any stakes.
I think this time,
let's,
let's give this a time for a bunch of
fucking assholes to chime in online.
You know,
bunch bunch of us to sit around and
think about devious ways we could trick
each other to do it.
Something that seems okay.
It's really more difficult.
Like per pete and Tom and I'm being so
nice,
but not even suggesting you beating him
by running him on skates.
I'm not even suggesting that because
that's just ridiculous,
but I'm thinking maybe like half,
maybe half as the real bet.
He doesn't.
The giotto things,
any way you'll lose way.
There's no way to just in 15 years,
straight hours not quitting.
A two and a half hours to I'm going to
get.
I'm high as fuck.
He's going to be thinking about the
universe to steroids and electromagnetic
fields.
If it all comes down to whether or not
who's gonna tire out,
he's going to get hot and retires out.
He's got no heart,
no heart every 30 yards a vaporizer.
If there's no quit in Tom,
there's no way he won't feature.
I have A.
Oh,
if he have you quit your job,
quit.
He'll quit quitting wheels are faster
than not wheels squealing.
No,
no,
no.
I agree.
Yeah,
but if he.
If he quits,
which is partly possible,
birth things,
he's holding onto some logical linchpin
here.
Tell us,
tell us what,
why you think it'll definitely go your
way.
I'll have many reason not fatigue.
Arrested after the best one.
Mickey Mantle Gene's number number one.
There's so much more weight on a scale
than the results just to pick.
Every time he's gotta go.
He's
picking up an extra 10,
14 new muscles how to use them.
You do get so after you escaped for the
first time to his thoughts will be on
fire and he'll be sitting down and the
rabbit or the turn toward us will run
right past them and go,
what?
Did you have a good time?
Rabbit.
Did you chase your bird of a turtle?
Myrtle.
The turtle.
Turtle.
The turtle burst top Tommy Skates.
We will follow up on this.
Oh,
I think just the way he exits like he's
to it now.
Just not know.
Half my bet was ridiculous,
but you can't.
You think you're going to beat wheels?
Two wheels.
He would take off and I'd be like,
Ha,
fools just holding onto my shirt as I
jog the same on the same track.
You're passionate because he got had in
the beginning and you'd be like,
Hey,
I'm up for that time.
Are you on some rollerskating?
People reach out.
I gotta get ready.
Get ready.
I can't listen tonight.
Everybody.
We're happy.
We've got dates here.
We've got some of us tickets to the
trump.
Hold on.
Comedy dates,
comedy dates.
What do you got?
Port Chester,
New York Capitol Theater in New York
City.
So Saturday with number 25th year in Los
Angeles for God.
Congratulate our sphere.
What are you doing for new years?
I am not doing anything for.
New Year was just a house party.
I am starting my 2018 tour.
My first tour in 14 months here.
The city's just for the winter.
Asheville,
Athens,
Boston,
providence,
comments and foxwoods.
Denver,
Seattle,
Boise,
Vancouver,
Edmonton.
Probably another one or two star check.
Asheville was a strong start.
I love that place.
I got to get back to you.
Dirty hippies and every to every Sunday
I'm doing my new hour at the comedy
cellar for crusher Irvine Improv this
weekend.
And then we're almost sold out first
show Wilbur,
uh,
in February third and truck to show sold
out or three shows sold out.
Adding a fourth of February,
22nd 23rd and 24th website.
[inaudible] DOT com.
That's it.
Do you think you'll quit?
I know it's not going to quit.
Definitely.
It's going to be fun.
NAB episode two.